yep for the committee my name is Frank
Guetta blue I'm the commissioner of
education for the Department of
Education and I have some Focus Allen
Court I'm the CFO
okay and then I thought what I would do
is just start out with a basic overview
and then we can dive into details as you
like
um the first page in that presentation
is an organization chart of the agency
and as you can see we have four
different divisions
um I will point out that the division of
Workforce Innovation does not have a
director and has not had a director for
over 10 years so it is a position but
it's just not a funded position
uh the Deputy Commissioner oversees the
principal activities in that division
including vocation Rehabilitation as
well as SSDI
we've got the division of educator
analytics and resources which again is
Caitlin's division including activities
such as assessment and accountability
our Charter Schools our EFA our
Innovation schools all of our reporting
functions and our data activities of
which there are many
we've also got the division of learner
support and Melissa white is here I
would drag her up here but you're out of
table space at this point in time
um and so Melissa is the director of the
division of learner support which
includes all of our title programs uh
title two three four a four B idea etc
etc
has CTE our office of student wellness
which includes food as well as student
wellness and mental health our Esther
programming so a lot of the educational
related programming and then we have the
division of educator support in higher
education Stephen Appleby is for a
second so we can get a one of the
foreign
we'll give Ken that extra book as well
so uh Stephen Appleby is the division
director and that includes all of the
credentialing functions
um as well as higher education
commission and the career schools so
that is the basic uh divisional
structure of the agency
on the next slide this is my favorite
slide relative to the Department of
Education and our agency because in one
slide you can see everything that's
happening at the agency
at the top you can see the funding that
goes into our K-12 education system and
what some of those sources are whether
those are coming from General funds
federal funds education trust fund other
funds to give you a total as well
although on a delayed basis because we
don't always have that information right
away we show the local education
spending that comes through relative to
our K-12 system we then have our
enrollment numbers our average cost per
pupil and again sort of a snapshot of
the revenue side of uh and I'm going to
spend I can spend some more time walking
through this because there's a lot of
details I get it but it is convenient
that you have everything in one place to
be able to see it all
um and then you get down uh further down
you see where those funds are deployed
how we are using those uh the first is
General funds state aid you can see over
time much of those funds have moved into
different places or have been phased out
and I'm happy to work through you know
each of those changes but some of those
have happened in Prior years the two
items that remain in there are both are
Statewide special education Aid at fifty
thousand dollars and our career and Tech
student organizations at uh fifty
thousand dollars
um
and principally uh you know these are
General funds that are used
um you know the career and text student
organizations I mean I can tell you that
I have heard from our CTE programs they
would like to see more funding uh
towards those programs uh principally
These funds are used to provide stipends
to Educators who Mentor the various
programs like our FFA or some other
program like that
um and then again moving down you get to
the next Group which is General funds
pass through state aid and the reason
why we designate this is because I know
that um we all live and die by lapse uh
in terms of how we're going to make our
budget and one of the things that we
wanted to make clear is that we don't
actually get to put our our hands on
these funds you give them to us and we
hand them off to somebody else right
there's no chance you're going to get a
lap so if you're aiming at like a three
percent lapse it's not like you can
lapse money that you don't get to touch
you just you receive it and we pass it
through and there have been some changes
in terms of movements between categories
that we can discuss but uh you know it
includes court order placements
scholarships for Orphans and Veterans
the New England Board of higher
education
the school nutrition programming parts
of it anyways this state assessment
which we'll spend some time talking
about
CTE vocational Ed State adult education
VR field program match uh Individual
Services this is part B for
individuals who are blind and a robotics
program
um and then just you can see some of the
uh movements that have taken place but I
think actually I'm going to highlight
those when I get down to the last
category
um and then the next line item is really
I like to say this is what we actually
have some degree of control over uh it's
in terms of the funding that we're
spending in the agency to run the agency
it includes a salary benefits and
insurance line and a doit rent phone and
other and these are the allocations that
we get from Department of administrative
services
and then if I continue to move down
further you can see the education trust
fund which includes a variety of
components a building Aid component
there was a conversation before the
meeting started relative to the building
a because the perception is that the
building Aid is 50 million and in fact
it is the other component of that sits
over in Treasury and is interest on
bonds that is being serviced so there is
a 50 million appropriation there it's
just split between two agencies
um uh District public school adequacy
which is pretty straightforward we
understand what that is tuition and
transportation is associated with our
CTE programming the charter school
adequacy again adequacy for all of our
New Hampshire public charter schools
State Testing and assessment and we'll
spend a little bit of time talking about
that particular line item because we
again stuff has been moved around
kindergarten Aid which was an initial
startup program that's now included and
um special education Aid which is our
state special education funding that is
provided uh building lease Aid primarily
associated with the charter school
leases but I think it's been opened up
now to no okay so just chart school this
Aid yep I know there was talk about
changing that okay education Freedom
accounts which I'm sure will spend a lot
of time talking about the fa phase out
grants Public School infrastructure fund
um is not in there uh in in the current
budget
ETF administrator for student
information system this is our Alma
program our Statewide student
information system associated with the
slds so we have a Federal grant that
helps with this as well as the state
funding for this particular application
it is a Statewide student information
system that we I've been advocating for
this one for a long time since I got to
the agency we are literally going to be
saving districts uh man years of time
and I can explain to you the Arcane
process of getting information to the
schools and getting information from the
schools that is very difficult and and
sometimes inaccurate you'll see Lottery
revenue is funded at one dollar and
again this is a an accounting placement
where we're just like setting up a new
account and I'm happy to walk you
through that and then code order
placements I missed down below so some
of the the numbers that I want to walk
through is I'll start with quarter
replacement since I just finished you'll
see that that came out of state
pass-through Aid it was funded at two
it's historically been funded at a
million and a half then we increased it
to 2 million it's now at a number of
4.516 million the way that this works is
that under the law if a student is
placed in an educational setting by the
court that we have the authority to draw
a warrant to pay for that right because
anytime they place the kids
um you know we historically have funded
it and uh and then we ended up going
back and asking for a warrant to fund it
and so each time when we submit a budget
we always just submit an amount that we
think it's going to be as opposed to
what it turns out so we estimate right
now that it'll be about 4.5 million
thank you Mr chair historically that has
never been in the education Trust
um and um if in fact it
does exceed that amount it has to be by
law
um that has to be filled
and in that it's in the education trust
you have assembled it there
um that in turn would draw down more
money from the trust what was your
rationale for taking it out of the trust
please
um I think that the governor believed
that the education trust fund um was the
appropriate place for this because it is
specifically funding for the education
of these students right so it's not for
this is not
um providing any types of other health
care services or mental health services
for these students who are adjudicated
these are court ordered correct these
are these are the these are the costs of
educating the court order place students
and one other thing that's probably
important to note as well is while we do
have warrant Authority relative to court
ordered placements there is as well if
the if the education trust fund was
short there is warrant Authority in the
education trust I understand that thank
you
um so that's that's a move that I wanted
to kind of flag for you so that you
would be able to uh to see that
um the other one that you will see is
we've also moved State assessment
um line item down so at least a portion
of that came down to uh the education
trust fund as well and I think what
you'll see in this budget is trying to
reflect in the education trust fund all
the costs associated with education so
that we make it clear what it is that
we're spending to educate the students
here in New Hampshire so that was
another item that was transferred out of
one into the other that one does not
have warrant Authority
specifically as a line item
and let me just go through these other
line items if anything else I want to
flag for you
um you'll see as well in adult education
in the general funds state pass-through
that increased about 300 000 and that
was an increase that
um we were seeking associated with our
adult education programming and what
we're finding in adult education program
which has been a phenomena that has been
taking place over ever since I've been a
commissioner here is that you see an
increasing number of high school
students mostly 11 and 12th graders who
are leaving the traditional educational
setting and going to the adult education
programming to be able to get their
education uh last year we had 1700 11th
and 12th graders who left the
traditional education setting and went
to the adult education setting to finish
their education get their High School
foreign thank you Mr chair
um devil dead has been pretty
consistently funded um would you be
adverse to raising that to to 5 million
per year of the biennium uh so Adult Ed
serves a tremendous purpose in our
communities I agree yeah and they do
agree and particularly the students
um that they're serving our kids who are
not having success and you're finding a
success degrees Adult Ed programs
um so the only um so I have no problem
if if you do we're going to support and
we're going to you know serve those
students
um what we have to just be careful of is
we don't want we want to make sure that
we keep the Right Mix because we receive
a significant amount of federal funds
there as well and we want to make sure
that we don't jeopardize our federal
funds um because we've two things can
happen one is we increase those funds
and we over serve uh the non-adult
population and that would jeopardize our
funds
alternatively we have matches associated
with that program we want to make sure
that we don't supplant something that we
ultimately can't recover back in a
federal ground so my question is would 5
million
work so what I can tell you is that the
amount that we've put in there the
additional three hundred thousand
dollars I think we can support I mean
this is going to support a whole other
person I think we can support that
Community I don't know that I need
additional funding beyond that at this
point in time so I'm making the ask and
uh and I think I'm okay at that you know
within the context if we have the funds
we will try and deploy them as efficacy
as we possibly can
um so I do think that we needed more
money to support this population of
students and so I've asked for that
oh thank you Mr chairman and then we'll
as well I'm gonna I'm gonna take you
through a bunch of other slides that
sort of explain some of this further and
then there might be more questions also
well maybe maybe I'll hold off okay I
just wanted to flag for you a couple of
the different line items there so we can
keep moving on if I go to my next page
of the presentation
um I just want to reconcile for everyone
the changes between the agency phase and
the governor's phase because I know
that's a question that I always get and
there you can see we talked about
assessment which was moved from the
general funds line item down into the
education trust fund line item we talked
about court ordered placement moving as
well and then in terms of we also have
uh two CTE centers as you know that we
generally are refurbishing two CTE
centers every biennium
um and we had uh you know Sugar River
and winter Squam were both in the queue
you'll notice that one they were moved
out of the capital budget into the
operating budget they are education
expenses so they've moved that and then
as well when a Squam does not yet have a
positive vote last year they voted they
were close they didn't get there and so
that has not been carried forward in the
governor's phase of the budget because
it had not passed uh doesn't have a
warrant article it is on it is on the
ballot this spring in March and it may
or may not pass but we don't know the
answer to that
um so those are just some of the changes
to help reconcile for you in your own
minds
um on the next slide I assume that there
would be much conversation about the
education Freedom account expansion and
so you can see the categories of
students that we have recommended
expanding and that was in the agency
budget and that includes a 500 percent
cap on federal poverty level that was
added in the governor's face of the
budget for these individual categories
of students
and then on the next slide you have our
prioritized need that um as you know we
we give our agency budget and we flag
our prioritized needs and so one of the
items that we had as our prioritized
need was our school security so this is
our as you know we've done a number of
different grant opportunities to schools
to enhance uh the physical security of
the facilities and the sites and my
perspective is that this is the kind of
thing that we just want to fund on a
consistent basis rather than kind of a
hit and a miss and be reactionary and so
we had recommended five million dollars
a year of just spending on continuing to
make sure that we have
um you know the the best Security
Options in our schools we have uh you
know this last year we funded projects
as an example we received we opened up a
grant window last summer we had we
solicited you know requests from school
districts for security measures we
prioritize access control because we
believe that that was kind of the first
level of protection that we wanted to
wrap around our students and our staff
who were in these facilities we were
able to fund 100 of the requests for
Access security projects we have
continued to seek other alternative
types of funding opportunities for that
and we think that we have between 7 and
10 million dollars more funding through
some through some federal programming
that we can bring to these funds but
we'll continue to just try and find
funding opportunities to bring forward
thank you Mr chair and thank you
commissioner and everybody else my
apologies for being a few minutes late I
I still need to learn how snow Works
apparently
um in regards to you know Access Control
in schools
obviously there is a need we have to
protect the facilities but I just wanted
to check if you if the department is
focusing on providing the funds for the
you know physical construction that is
needed or you also spend time working on
you know training the staff or offering
resources to train the staff because
having One Secured entry point in the
building doesn't do that much if there
are other uh very unsecured and wide
open access points uh which in my
experience has been the case in a lot of
the schools that I've been looking at so
are we you know what are we doing
something in regards to training and
operations rather than just facilities
yeah so I mean it's a it's a simple
question but a big answer so I'll try
and like uh you know boil it down so the
the latest so we work hand and glove
really with Homeland Security in terms
of making sure that we are being
responsive to the appropriate needs in
the buildings part of that work means
that every single school is required
hired to do a Emergency Operations plan
and a security assessment homeland
security goes into the schools and we
started these a number of years ago goes
into the schools and evaluates that plan
and does a security evaluation in the
actual building itself
they provide recommendations to the
schools if I go back into the 2018 time
frame we had funding of about 30 million
dollars and those those grants were used
to do both a lot of a broader array of
security mitigation measures including
vestibules and secure entrances and
those were done only if they were a
mitigation that was recommended by
Homeland Security in these latest Grant
rounds we have not funded larger capital
projects because what you'll find is
that a single vestibule can cost like
two million dollars if you're you know
if you have to build it so these have
been focused more on you know three
types of of mitigating control so access
controls
you know notification and emergency
response right so those are the kind of
three things so Access Control keeping
people out notification means if
somebody is in the building that you
have the ability to notify so that you
can get emergency responders there and
then the emergency response is how we
can get them more efficient in their
response to the thing so whenever we do
those programs they include a variety of
different training programs that would
come along with that and as well schools
themselves have the ability to do
training and they have in law they have
certain training that they're required
to do in terms of practicing certain
emergency drills and stuff like that so
I don't know if that's helpful
very helpful and I appreciate a
comprehensive approach that's you know
taken because that's what we need in
order to really secure those buildings
so thank you very much for the details
okay and I and I agree with you I think
we need a comprehensive approach and we
need a consistent approach as opposed to
a reactionary approach
um and so that's what that initial thing
was
um the next slide um another regular
question is just like the Staffing and
you know what we have in our staffing
and so we currently have 291 employees
there are 13 new positions 7ds that have
been requested through this process
generally funded so a Ed analytics
resources so this would be in Caitlyn's
division it is really just um you know
trying to make sure we've got good data
relative to those students and keeping
track of where our students are and
where they're moving the second is in
adult education this is that funding
that I talked about previously which
would fund somebody to focus on making
sure we're supporting those high school
students in our adult ed programs
depending on where the legislature goes
with Early Child childhood we've got two
positions for early childhood education
and then we've got eight federally
funded programs one of those or five of
those are in special education and this
really revolves around a program that we
started about five years ago maybe
actually maybe six years ago at this
point in time it's called Universal
Design for Learning
udl it is an approach to make sure that
our teachers are trained to meet the
needs of all the kids in there we have
worked with an organization called cast
which was the developer of udl for a
number of years under contract
and that was helpful as we began to
build our capacity and our experience
with this stuff we now feel comfortable
enough that we can now bring that
activity in-house and meet the needs for
lower for a lesser cost and so
essentially what we're doing is we're
just going to assimilate that activity
into the department for udl vocation
Rehabilitation this is a Nashua position
that we're hiring if you might remember
like a couple years ago I tried to phase
out the Nashua office and integrate it
with some stuff and we thought that we
would better be able to serve our
customers that way and essentially what
we're doing is we we kind of we shut
down our national office and we moved in
with other partners that serve the same
types of individuals what we're finding
is it's not as effective as I thought it
would be and so we're going to move
forward again and just have our separate
national office so
um you know we have been looking for
lease space and so this would be for an
office manager there because we had the
same Personnel but we then those
Personnel were working in community
centers and other non-profits that were
serving these same folks thinking like
well if they have to go to the community
center to get their SNAP benefits or
this other benefit why don't we just
meet with them there rather than make
them have another stop it's not as easy
to coordinate with all of those other
organizations as we had hoped and so we
just think it's better we probably
continue to serve them better on our own
and then we have two individuals
relative to assessment and
accountability what you'll find is that
the federal data requirements around
assessment and accountability they just
keep going they keep turning the volume
higher and higher in terms of what
information they need what information
they want how you do that
um
for Melissa and Nate spent decades you
know getting complying with uh you know
pure peer review associated with the
assessments just like a level of
granularity that's even difficult to
imagine
um and so those so that is relative to
the assessment and the accountability
side of that is again the reporting
associated with that
um and then one education trust fund uh
person as you can see the education
trust fund is becoming a much much more
highly complex accounting function uh
we're spending you know over a billion
dollars through there and we just think
it's important that you have somebody
who's basically like a and a fund
manager essentially for the billion
dollar fund not that we're not managing
it now but someone who's dedicated to
that and so that's what those positions
are and then the last slide and then we
can just go back through and talk about
anything that we want
um is the capital budget requests and
again I I kind of mentioned this already
so and I only I flagged that here I
realize that I'm in division two and I'm
not at the capital committee but as you
know the Sugar River is now in the
education and trust funds so that falls
within your domain but these were the
two CTE centers that were proposed in
the capital budget and then again Sugar
River is now in the um in the operation
budget in the education trust fund and
so that's kind of an overview of the
budget and now we can let's now we'll
get the detailed Pages sent again thank
you Mr chair I just want to go to the
positions again okay um you've got
currently 291. what's your breakdown
Federal
um General
uh do I have that on that sheet I don't
have that broken down on my sheets so
I'm gonna I'm going to say we have
approximately 60 65 General maybe 25
other and then the remaining is federal
and others would be in your
credentialing correct yeah and what
you'll find is can I just can I follow
up on that question as well because
actually if I go back to my summary
sheet you'll find that we did move
um some positions around into General
funds so for example if I go to my like
spreadsheet here some of the font you'll
see an increase in general funds one of
those increases is so I have two people
that work in federal compliance is what
we've called it and the difficulty with
them being 100 federally funded in
federal compliance is that if I have to
do a compliance thing associated with
State programs you know like a food
program maybe if it's a state food
program or a CTE program or something
like that they can't work on it right
because they're federally funded so they
can only work on the federal programs
and so what we basically did is we moved
their positions down into the general
funds and then we're going to fill them
out to the federal programs and have the
federal crimes pay for them and that way
if I ask them to do uh you know to look
at something on a general fund basis
they we have the funding it's a
legitimate use of their activities so so
um
New Hampshire gets the minimum allotment
in its federal funds usually small state
minimums I guess they call it in some of
the programs um so in special education
um I have a question that has been asked
of me so I will ask it of you
um apparently
um over the years we've had many more
special ed positions federally funded
positions in the department of Ed that
work primarily only with special
education and
um and they are paid under idea funds
and now those positions there I guess
there are about three or
three to six have not been filled and my
question is
um
what happens to those funds
um how are those funds used and
um how are you meeting the
the idea guidelines are pretty stringent
um you know in when you live in the
world of of compliance
um it takes a lot of Manpower so how are
you meeting that and then how are you
meeting the needs of people out in the
communities because special ed is always
a Hot Topic it is yeah and I think and
thank you for that question because I
think it's a good one
um I what is the number of open
positions
and it's not because we don't want to
find them we just can't find him he
hired them yes exactly so what's going
on is that we have a very high vacancy
rate in special education right now I
mean like the schools who are having
difficulty finding special education
folks in the schools we too are having
difficulty
um and they get to pay more than we do
as well so generally when we compete
with them they're able to recruit those
people more quickly how we're doing it
is you know we're basically you know
people are working harder so we've got
overtime in the division uh and in the
bureau
um and then we're just trying to be
smart in terms of deploying our
resources to that most at-risk places so
if we're doing a monitoring or something
like that we're trying to prioritize
okay if I can't monitor 10 I can only
monitor eight like where am I going to
go at that point in time so that's
pretty much how we're doing it but there
is no we if I had my druthers like so
these are not positions that we're
leaving vacant because it's federal
funds right right
um so we're happy to go ahead and hire
those positions that we can find them if
we can't find them then generally what
we'll do is we may do like a one-year
contract for somebody and say like okay
so you go do this for us or
um any any way we can to just trying to
keep up with Mission all right thank you
thank you Mr chair just a quick question
if she has anybody for us to send him
our way okay
it's a quick follow-up right whenever
you say difficulty finding qualified
people usually there are many reasons
for that one of the ones that was talked
about a lot during this budget process
is uh you know licensing and is is this
a place obviously we still have issues
with just availability of Workforce with
you know training and paying all that
but just talking about licensing for a
moment is there anything in this
particular proposal that would make it a
bit easier to maybe accept licenses from
other states from people that are
qualified so we have an easier time
recruiting or is it you know not
necessarily covered in this one yeah so
that wouldn't affect us because we don't
have a licensing requirement for the
individuals that we hire we basically
are trying to hire people who have the
skill set that we need in the agency and
so we're not limited by whether they're
licensed or not we're limited because
there's not enough people who have the
experience working in the special
education domain for that
thank you and it's not as much a
follow-up as a leftover question from an
earlier Point
um you were saying that you are gonna
move to people from being funded
federally to the general fund for the
ability to deploy them either for
federal work and then you'll deal back
yeah
would it be okay to ask for a report you
know two years from now when we are back
here on uh what percentage of that was
actually charged back to the federal uh
funds based on you know how they were
used just to have a better understanding
because right now if I would ask you
what percentage of the time you know it
would be hard to tell but just to give
us data so we understand you know
because we're putting two people on
general fund but we're expecting a
revenue right they're going to get
pulled back out exactly and I'm just
trying to figure out what's the best way
for us to forecast the net impact going
forward yeah so that's an easy thing for
us to do because what we basically do we
have a process and on a quarterly basis
we have like a Time collection system
where we're billing out to those
programs so you don't have to wait two
years the next time we close the books
we could show you who got billed out and
where they got billed out too it would
be appreciated if it would be included
just because again we need to understand
what the burden to the general fund is
thank you Mr chairman
um at its Inception the education trust
fund was strictly to to pay for adequacy
and we always managed to adjust it so
that it was just a little bit less than
adequacy and then we filled it up with
general fund because we felt if we went
over
the money would be lost
so
now
obviously the education trust fund with
the reduction in student enrollment is
producing more than that one of the ways
is we can put a lot of more stuff in the
education trust fund or we could take
the law that puts parts of the various
taxes and reduce the amount going which
is my preference because
I don't want to put money in education
trust fund that goes through a lapse
that we really needed somewhere else
so that's that's my Approach was would
be try to reduce the fractions of the
other taxes that are going to the
education trust fund since the need is
less yes so certainly an option right
you got debits and you got credit so you
can either like if you have too many
credits you can put more debits in there
if you you know if you don't put more
debits in there you can reduce the
number of credits that go in which would
be the revenue side of that so either
way it balances out the trust fund I
think what we want to do is the two
aspects we want to try and focus on is
we want you know to have a long-term
perspective relative to the education
trust fund and make sure that to your
point we're trying to balance it on
parity we're not trying to create a
large Surplus balance there now we're
trying to figure out what are the
associated costs of running this thing
and that's the revenue that we should
put in there and I think that that's an
appropriate philosophy and thank you you
already gave me a copy of this okay
somebody else then okay
so it's a good read then is what you're
saying yes
um
this is a very good visual okay what's
been going on for the last few years
that's was my favorite one right and we
have it for years before that but it
gets too small and then you can't read
it so if you want or the more years we
have them but it's fairly obvious that
things are marching down into the
educational cross fund over time
what about any of the general fund
salary and benefit moving into education
RSA or is it just by practice it's not
it's not it's not restricted it's where
you want to fund it I mean we all are
working on educational activities so
um it's a little bit more to
representative Weiler's question is like
you know how do you balance the debits
and the credits is really what you're
after so well do you want to comment do
you have a thought on that I heard you
large flow through programs
are these large military programs that
are going specifically to school
districts to can't the department you
would never see last one maybe from the
Department of Education on those types
of programs there's little to no
flexibility on how those funding
resources are distributed things like
building a pretty prescriptive and law
adequacy obviously extremely
prescriptive and specifically a law and
so those kind of are the programs that
have which is marked down to the
education trust funded over the years
whereas the more General operational
type expenses have always continued to
remain in general fund and again I don't
know for sure what the to your point
like there's this March down to the
education trust fund and I'm not sure if
that is uh you know to representative
Wilder's position well there is funding
there therefore the debits are attracted
to it as opposed to reducing the credits
and let them get paid for someplace else
yes I recall at one time you had
positions that were 50 Federal 50 state
or 75 20. still do yeah you still do
okay because I was curious when you said
person working on this couldn't work on
because so we do yeah so we already had
some that we have balanced out but then
what was happening is our federal
compliance we saw like a lot of state
laws that are being passed that you guys
are wanting us to can you go look at
this you know is the school doing this
or did they file their doe 25 you know
on the state finances or something like
that and we're like well we don't I mean
if Caitlin or Idaho doesn't do it we
don't have anybody who's funded in a way
that we could say like yes you know
Lindsay who is our compliance person can
you go look at x and y z school district
and see what's going on and why they're
late on their doe 25 as an example
responsibility to change
so well I mean if we move them into the
general funds then we have the ability
to to build to to further to do that
yeah so they would just do
proportionally so we uh so we basically
are doing time collection we have time
sheets that people are submitting it's
almost like a like an accounting firm or
a law firm Caitlyn and I are familiar
with accounting firms in our background
but
um so you just do time time claiming
against it and that's where that goes
and so essentially what we do is we do
estimates as to where people think
they're going to be spending their time
on a quarterly you know so they look
forward
um and then that time is you know at the
end of that quarter then you reconcile
what did you actually spend your time on
do we have the right allocations
um that's how we do it
I mean into you know going back a step
further and it's probably more detail
than you're interested in but to your
point representative Heath about
minimally funded States so you have some
of these programs you know take like a
migrant program that'd get them to pick
on right where they they give us so
little money that they don't even give
you enough money for somebody to
allocate 15 minutes of their time for
the program maybe and you're just like
how are we supposed to administer this
Federal ground when we can't do it right
so
I guess my question
followed on the idea of if you bring
less money in it'll stay in the general
fund but if you take some of your
general funds and put it in the
educational to us it's doing the same
thing
it's it's making more General funds
available somewhere else I mean it's
deficit credits have to balance that's
essentially what we're talking about
here yes and that's really I think a
philosophy that the legislature has to
decide what is the approach we want to
take right question
thank you uh maybe it's more of a
comment um the education Trust
in it originally I remember going way
back when it was initiated really it was
to provide adequacy funding to school
districts
um now all of a sudden it seems to be
because it has a surplus it never had a
surplus before usually it had to take
funds from the general fund to come into
the education trust
um I just would hate to see it swayed
from its general purpose
um by Statute many many years ago I
think that funding public education I
have to say that having the education
Freedom accounts in the education trust
bothers me greatly but that's my my
opinion
um but um
the intent was as we spent many hours
talking about getting more funds to
public schools and so I would I would
really like to keep it targeted to
public schools so I think as you do that
I think the systemic thing that you want
to consider is
um you know when it was originally set
up you had a revenue Source right so we
had these various Revenue sources that
we put in there those have been growing
over the years indeed and but over that
same period of time we've had fewer
students so we have less students in the
education system so essentially these
these two it's unlikely that those two
are going to begin to converge again and
so they're going to continue to pull
apart so we just have to decide what is
the philosophy that we want to have I
agree thank you could I ask one more
question while I'm here
um I had a question
um about in your your department you're
asking for one more position and what
was that position going to do
so which tell me which position in your
Commissioner's Office you are asking for
an additional position
just I just wanted to know what it was
what that was the purpose yeah I'm not
sure what page you're on was that the
analyst
division are you
looking I was looking at the budget and
um in the budget on page 1103
um in your in your office of the
commissioner you have
um
the number of positions
um you have
um an increase from four to five four to
five
yes
where was she before she was we had her
last year she's had her for several
years
I don't know the answer is that it
uh it might have been a movement we
haven't added anybody to the
Commissioner's Office the only thing we
were either thinking well you're asking
for it
yeah I'm trying to remember where that
came okay all right let me know the
answer is that okay commissioner yes
fair enough fair enough not good well it
may also be
um
you know in the governor's
recommendation he's recommended an
additional computer science person and
it could be that that is what that
Edition was okay which is why because
what I can tell you is I don't know of
anybody that we're adding to the
Commissioner's Office
can I continue
um now I also noticed I believe and I
did not know and I say congratulations
to you because I hear that you have now
um assumed the ownership of not you
personally but the state has taken over
grandest State the old Grand estate
college to be the Department of
Education well so we right now are
basically lessor or lessee yeah from the
University system of New Hampshire so
just kind of full context uh you know at
the University system of New Hampshire
we Consolidated uh Granite State College
into UNH and so they no longer needed
that space simultaneously our building
was uh deemed uninhabitable I get it uh
but you knew that right yes exactly you
have you been there yeah and so it just
was convenient that we were able to move
over there
um and so uh working with the Department
of administrative Services
it made sense for us to put in a capital
budget request which we did to acquire
25 Hall Street
um and move in there as a permanent
location that has not happened that
would be up to the legislature whether
or not they want to acquire that
facility or not if they don't we will
either continue to lease it or we will
once again become Nomads and um and to
do our job which is fine and I will say
that it is a convenient space
relative to its location on the highway
and one of the facts that many people
don't know about the Department of
Education is we do have quite a number
of
um
uh you know outside people come in we
have like over 7 000 unique visitors a
year that come to our department
um it allows us so it allows us to both
make it easy access for them as opposed
to driving around the office Park and
trying to find us
um it also
um has some spaces so that we don't have
to go outside and find spaces so for
example yesterday we I don't know how
anybody come to the presentation
yesterday so we did a presentation
yesterday for legislators and about
school funding so we're able to do that
we're able to do uh programming that we
would do for educators that normally
might happen outside and we'd have to
find a facility we're able to do it in
that facility so
um we're happy with the facility but um
so that's kind of where we are is that
does that answer your questions probably
more information than you need it but
it's the best perfectly and one final
question
um in this document I saw that the um
um survey the um youth risks yrbs yes is
not funded
uh
there was a governor who's that the
governors
perfect because if you recall the way
that worked it's like we got the money
but they did the work and we're like
well we didn't need to launder the money
for them we just like send it directly
thank you Mr chairman
we have a long spell with no building a
because obviously the schools were
downsizing nobody needed to build a new
school because of increased students
but then we have in this Spate of people
that want to
build no schools anyway
but the thing that troubles me like
recently here in Concord we heard from
the superintendent they gave away to
schools sold the third for who knows
what
and then come and ask us for hundreds of
thousands to build a new hundreds of
millions right to build a new school
to me you just gave away millions of
dollars of taxpayers funded buildings
that should have been sold and that
money should have been used for any
building any new school don't come to us
after you give away building buildings
and say oh by the way we need a new one
that should be removed from eligibility
if you're not fully utilizing all the at
all the assets that you have in your own
School District
we're going to Discount that when you
ask for more money another one I heard
of was
a school went up for bids the only
bidder was a charter school we're not
going to sell to them you should be
removed if you're doing that kind of
thing if you're not selling it for the
best bid and you're not refused to sell
it to a charter school or you're giving
away buildings
you are ineligible in my mind we should
change that criteria I don't know who I
have to get to because yep so that
criteria is in law
um so there's the statute is 198. 188 15
right and so there's a criteria for how
we evaluate them so if you were to add
that criteria in then that's where we
would add it to the checklist there are
oh sorry sorry
um so well so two things one Amy is here
and we'll be talking about building Aid
shortly and getting into some of the
more of the details but I just a
reminder there are caps on the building
a program right now for projects that we
funded in the past so if we have funded
a school on the last I believe it's 35
years you are ineligible for additional
funding relative to that school so there
are some limitations in the current law
and aim you can go over those in detail
and I think there's a limitation as well
like if you if we fund a project and you
abandon that project and you see
theoretically can be asked for that
funding back very good thank you
but can I just relative to the school
building funding though and I know that
um you know again Amy's going to be up
here talking about it but what we want
to do is just like we talked about the
education trust fund having kind of this
Divergence the revenue is going up and
the number of students are going down
when we think about the school funding
in buildings we want to build with a
long-term perspective right we have to
meet the short-term need but we have to
understand what the long-term
perspective is relative to the the
facility needs are going to be you know
okay so well we're set if you have
questions and then we've basically got
two other presentations that we wanted
to do one is relative to school building
Aid and I think Amy is prepared to come
up and talk to that
um and then we were going to do an
entire time on adequacy by Mark and
Caitlin uh you know so that you could
dig in and go through that as well okay
I think we have one more question two
more questions okay
thank you Mr chairman
um
getting back to court order placements I
see it went up from 2 million to 4.5 yep
and
why why why why why such an increase so
here's what's going on there so
typically so 4.5 is closer to the amount
that we typically spend but because
we're able to draw a warrant and I think
what happens sometimes in the budget
process is uh it's easier to write 2
million and then I just have to draw the
warrant later so it's not in the budget
and so we're just putting in the budget
we did this last time too we just put in
a budget well we think it's actually
going to be and then you all set a
number for us and then we just pay out
what it's going to be
yeah it's based on the actual
expenditures right yeah yeah thank you
uh also does YDC have any effect closing
of YDC there's a heading effect or is it
is that going to increase because of the
closing of YDC no I don't think that
that would affect it I mean we've been
working closely with YDC relative to the
education program that's going on in
there now and when those kids come out
they're already court ordered that is
their placements right
pretty good uh additional question here
um adult education finishers
that are not adults yeah how many how
many would you figure roughly uh about
1700 students 1700 so I often tease
Sarah Wheeler who runs that program that
she runs the largest High School in New
Hampshire because that's principally
just 11th and 12th graders right so
she's not got uh you know necessary
generally you don't she's not going to
see freshmen and uh sophomores in those
programs so that's a form of school
choice right I mean really uh sometimes
it's not even a choice sometimes there's
a source like some districts and I think
uh representative Heath can attest to
this at some schools are saying to kids
like we don't really need you around
here like wouldn't it be better if you
go over here but we're just happy to
serve them
right
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
commissioner I just um was noticing
perhaps I missed it um did you skip a
slide in regards to the EFA account
expansion no so did you speak about it
briefly I just I did speak about it
briefly and I assume that if you all had
questions that you'd be asking me a
question so if you have questions please
that it's a large item on the budgetary
outline that you just presented I think
a little bit further explanation would
be appropriate given the amount of money
that's being allocated to it yeah so
this is a tremendously successful
program with a high demand for the
program we are continuing and
recommending expansion of that program
to further subgroups of individuals that
are outlined on the slide in there that
include foster care students migratory
homeless child and youth students with a
parent in the armed forces some of our
English language Learners persistently
bullied students children with a
disability students within educational
hardships students in a geographic
boundary with Comprehensive support and
Improvement school which are low
performing Schools students in the
geographic jurisdiction of a school
which has been designated persistently
dangerous and a student eligible for
free and reduced price meals so in
addition to the increasing demand just
for students who are already
participating in that program or wanting
to come into that program because of the
current eligibility we've also expanded
so basically you're saying everyone
I I hope not does this include everyone
well one way or another you could
probably get everybody into that
category somehow but let me ask you a
question okay I am a product of Catholic
Education I went to uh Mount St Mary day
school I went to St Joe's High School
for Girls
um went on to
um a sectarian College
um and also public college but um
my parents paid
they always paid and they could very
well pay
um
I struggle
with the fact that our public schools
are not funded to the extent to which
they are funded and with the extent to
which you are opening up education
Freedom accounts basically
we know already that many and I think I
I think 80 percent of the people
currently taking an education Freedom
account already are in securing schools
or some kind of a private school you're
basically opening up
to the state of New Hampshire
the option of of an education of Freedom
account to just about everyone because
um any child in a public school that
that there are a lot of categories that
you've identified and then there are a
lot of kids for any number of reasons
could feel bullied or could be feeling
at risk
um so that's a pretty broad category so
help me to understand commissioner
please because I really am having a
problem okay I can help you with that so
just to be clear these are not uh
capricious titles that we've put in here
a student who is persistently bullied is
someone who is defined in
rsa193-ft F colon 3. so it's the
legislature who has created these
categories of students we're not
capriciously making those up but
certainly we know that a student who is
consistently bullied is going to have a
very difficult time ask accessing their
education and in fact you know because
you've worked at the agency and when we
see it we know that these kids are not
not doing well when they are
persistently bullied in a setting and so
we're not we're not making up new
definitions we're basically living with
and using the definitions that have
already been developed by the
legislature in these various categories
um the next point that I would make for
you is relative to and it's I'll make a
broader point and then I'm going to kind
of narrow it down a little bit but
um you know across the country there are
over 34 states that are introducing
choice programming into their states
um because the the parents the customers
so to speak are saying we want these
options for our children and they don't
want these options just again
capriciously but because they're trying
to find an educational pathway that
would be successful just let me finish
and then I'm sure you have some some
further questions and that would be
great you're trying to find an
educational pathway that would be
successful one of the things that I have
been working tenaciously on
is to to try and help our Public Schools
recognize that they can be that choice
right in other words the fact that uh
you know it's a public school it too can
be the school
that people choose and they want to go
to and in fact even in this program we
have students who have left their
resident district and chosen another
Resident District another District not
the residential because that's where
they want to go to school and so what
I'm trying to encourage more and more
and we've provided you know funding
we've provided Innovation grants to
schools to try and help the public
schools themselves embrace the idea of
choice and not say like well because I'm
a school everybody's required to go here
unless they pay for their education
sometimes twice by paying their local
taxes as well as the tuition to the
school so I don't like I don't I don't
see it as in either or I see the the
public schools having an option to be
the choice for the families and then I I
guess the last well I mean and so that's
what I would say is that it doesn't have
to be an either or it has to be a both
and we need our public schools to be
those choices and I can speak to I mean
just even in the last month I've met
with two superintendents and some some
choice programming and say like can we
bring these Choice programs to your
District to your school and and one of
the districts they've had families leave
to go to Choice programs and but we from
the very beginning were working with the
school saying why don't you just do this
this same district has had teachers
leave to start Choice programs and I
said like well why don't you just let
that teacher do it in your program right
there's nothing in our rules that would
prevent them from doing this and what
you're finding is I mean as an example
of some of these learning pod
opportunities across the country you
know these learning products teachers
are leaving the profession and they're
starting learning products and I'm
saying why don't you guys just work with
the teachers start the learning part
right in your district and so those are
the conversations that I'm having with
superintendents so that they can become
thank you Mr chair
public education was founded for the
common good
the
schools
what my concern is we are using public
funds
to
provide programming to students
attending any variety of sectarian or
other libertarian or
such schools
and I just find that New Hampshire right
now is blessed we are blessed to have an
extraordinary Surplus an extraordinary
amount of money I mean in your budget
you're asking for a very large amount of
money for the education Freedom accounts
when I know we have been fortunate to
have these funds first of all to be even
able to have this conversation and quite
frankly commissioner if I had had your
budget I would have been in tears for
Joy because believe me if we had 230 000
each year in the biennium for public
school Improvement it was a lot of money
and you know we we struggled
um and now we're kind of flush with cash
um in many areas we've never had a
conversation about taking
um building construction
um out of the education trust because it
was never even a possibility
so I just I feel like
with and we also this time we have the
covid money that came to schools so we
did have some extensive funding through
that but it just it troubles me so
greatly that this amount of money is
being set aside for this purpose when
there are so many
children that are in our public schools
that need so much and well anyway I can
go on forever but I I've had my say
Thank you Mr chair so so I'm happy to
respond to that
um
you know so second we're going to have a
conversation about the education uh
advocacy formula and I know that
Caitlyn's going to lead that and so
you'll see
um it's not that we've left anybody out
in this process but the other thing I
would just
reflect on is you mentioned that you
know public education is about a common
good but the good is an educated
citizenry
and what we know is that the
one-size-fits-all education model
doesn't affect a common good because it
leaves too many of our children behind
and so the good is not that they get to
go to a particular building or not the
good is that they're educated what we
all share as a uh you know as a state
and as a constitute of Republic is
we all benefit when our children are
educated well and so I think that's
really the objective of all of this
programming I think you know
representative Heath that I love
children incredibly and I want to do
everything that I can to make sure that
the children of New Hampshire every
single child has the best possible
opportunity for success and a bright
future
thank you commissioner we will just
always agree to disagree okay
thank you Mr chair and thank you
commissioner again
um I just wanted to
take a few minutes I'm afraid let me
start by asking if I may um if I
understand correctly the current change
in the eligibility for the EFA is an
expansion of the poverty you know to now
500 percent from a lower limit and also
you know this at risk subgroups do I
understand that correctly that for the
higher limit is for these at-risk
subgroups okay so you gotta meet both
criteria you've got to be within the 500
and belong to a high risk that's correct
nice well at risk group
so I just want to bring up a couple of
things which are again my personal
experiences representative as
representative Heath was mentioning her
upbringing that
we strongly believe in public schools we
used to live in Walton Massachusetts and
there came a point when those Public
Schools completely failed my eldest
child she was ahead of her you know
classmates and the teachers just ignored
her literally would give her nothing to
do we spoke with the teachers and said
look we don't ask for an equal amount of
time but could you just give her an
assignment at the beginning check on her
at the end maybe once in the middle of
the class we understand you gotta focus
more time on the kids who are falling
behind no problem with that nothing
happened we spoke with the principal
nothing happened so in the middle of the
year we had to pull our kids out of the
public schools that were absolutely
failing my child after making every
effort we could and take her to you know
Catholic School our lady is an academy
and welcome frankly you know we're in
the wrong state for me to plug them in
these hearings but they are an amazing
School
we didn't get a penny right
we just had to pay and all that taxpayer
tax taxpayer money that went to our
public schools to educate my kid did not
educate my kid my kid was left
uneducated
and you know I had to pay out of my
pocket I don't I I'm still bitter about
it I don't think that was fair yes we
could afford it and we happily did it
but there was a duty that the state
assumed to provide a good education to
my child that they failed to deliver and
that's the state of Massachusetts at
that time
when we moved to Windham we moved to
Windham for the public schools they are
great Public Schools you know we are
committed to them my kids went there had
a great experience we were fortunate
enough to be able to move to a town
where you know the schools met the
expectations and served our kids
properly I served on the school board
I'm currently running again for the
school board because I am committed to
making sure those scores are the best
they can be
but I'm looking at you know talking
about expanding this to everyone
we had a family a neighbor of ours that
had four kids both of them were doctors
every one of those kids went to Catholic
school they were living basically 72
thousand dollars every year on the table
because they were passing on our about
eighteen thousand dollar a year a kid
education and taking their kids to
public school those people would still
not get a dollar under the efas right we
are not
expanding it to you know people who
already really have that school choice
we have you know to expand it for the
people who even if they somehow can
barely make ends meet and send their
kids they are suffering hardships
because of that this is not meant for
you know people like me people like my
neighbors who you know were fine doing
that but
you know
I'm trying to think about you know the
best comparison and
probably this is a topic that's not
quite directly relevant but when we
provide health care right there are two
models in Europe in providing public
health care for everyone one is the
British model where the government is
trying to be both the payer and the
deliverer of services versus the German
Healthcare where the government collects
the funds and then uses a mix of public
and private there are different policy
options to providing education and I
think
we should consider whichever mix of
policies we have that would best serve
our kids
and really
our schools benefit
from this program there have been
research studies showing that when you
know people start having the ability to
move public school start start doing
better because they have to improve and
innovate to retain those kids and we all
benefit so
I would argue that
allowing parents to do what's right for
their kids and providing some measure of
limited support for them under specific
limited circumstances is good policy and
you know
I really appreciate you know hearing
everybody's perspective and
we are a committee because we bring a
lot of different perspectives to the
table and
one of the great things about this
Committee in particular is that you know
we really listen to each other and
I just wanted to say you know we may not
always vote the exact same way but I
think we do learn a lot from each other
and I appreciate you know hearing all
those different perspectives but I had
to share mine too on this topic
yeah
I just have a data question could you
tell me how many students you estimate
in the new categories that you're
defining
for the EMAs I don't have that
information because we don't know how
many are going to be taking advantage of
it so
thank you commissioner okay like I can
tell you I don't know how many kids fit
into I know how many kids for the child
with a disability
um you know and I know some of these
categories but other categories we don't
yeah so like another six what it is I
don't know how many people with a
disability
are 500 of the federal poverty level or
below
right uh thank you Mr chairman
um
adult education how many
adults in state prison or or even the
county jails do you service under the
adult because we have a big problem here
65 percent of the those folks do not
have a high school education or
equivalent so if we expect them to
because they're gonna a lot of them will
be getting out on the in the public yeah
and I mean it's just uh if you don't if
they don't have a trade or whatever if
they if they can't function they'll be
right back in there so recidivism is
very high so that actually doesn't come
through our adult dad program we have
Granite State High School which is a
separately chartered New Hampshire High
School that provides education in the
prison system so we basically operate a
high school in the prison that we we
support and we fund is that both state
prison and county jails so the county
jails we do not have educational
programming typically in the county
jails the individuals are there for 30
days or less there are some
circumstances where they're longer but
they're not
um they're long enough to be able to
engage them like the turnover is too
high to be able to engage them in
education programming as opposed to in
prison where we have individuals for a
number of years and we're able to work
with them every year I speak at a
graduation both at the women's prison
and the Men's prison relative to those
uh inmates and it's it's an incredible
experience to see these individuals who
have you know turned their lives around
and said like okay I might have been a
knucklehead before but I don't have to
be going forward and they're trying to
uh you know to really make something of
themselves and it's it's a proud moment
very you know thank you very much for
that
I just want to confirm that the the
dollars that are going to the uh Freedom
accounts yep are adequacy funds it's not
additional dollars the Stars will be
going somewhere anyway
I would be going to a student
enroll in public school
if a student is enrolled in public
school and they choose an education
Freedom account then those funds would
not go to that public school they would
go to the education Freedom account
right so this is not additional dollars
this is reallocational dollars for
correct okay
okay any other questions yeah I I know I
have one more comment uh Mr chair uh
when you when you expounded on uh you
know schools competing against each
other in districts I believe in Indiana
and you might have been there also they
actually advertise on billboards come to
this District because we have this you
know great math program or whatever and
that you know and they compete among
schools and that that's what it's doing
is making these uh schools come more
competitive so there are other states
that have uh similar programs Indiana
Ohio is one that has an open enrollment
program where students have more
flexibility in terms of moving around
you know that is again and what you're
seeing is more and more of this is
evolving across the country right so
we're not we're not on the Leading Edge
I know some individuals may want us to
believe that but there's a lot of other
states that have moved much further
ahead down this pathway and again the
both the the needs of the students the
needs of the states and the importance
of having an educated citizenry as well
as you know the national uh phenomena of
declining enrollment rates as well
are these kind of external forces that
are causing a need for evolution and
change and the status quo is not going
to be able to meet those going forward
yes I'm going to change the subject
completely
help me with preschool commissioner can
we do it please how can we figure out
how to find money in this huge budget
that you have that I really do find I
cannot believe just the line for um
memberships in different organizations
is so much more than it used to be when
I was Deputy we really charge a lot for
that don't they I they really do
um but you get a lot from it but
um across our country
Most states except the six provide
state-funded
pre-public Pre-K
um and in my bill 620 we're simply
asking for a a pilot and early learning
do you think that this is a feasible ask
for New Hampshire
um well as you'll notice that I do have
on my positions I propose to Early
Childhood positions relative to that
um and then I think as you know
Christine the Deputy Commissioner has
been working yes
um around this quite a bit uh to try and
move forward so we'll see where that
goes
So to that at that point it I wrote down
conditional
so if that if it doesn't become
law
uh then the you're not going to hire
these two or you're going to hire them
correct no so I if well first of all if
you don't approve them I'm not going to
hire them you know I'm talking about the
whole preschool yeah so these anticipate
working towards some of the pilots and
some of the other activities in the
but we're still on your agenda so
whatever you okay so then I think we'll
let Amy uh come up and talk about
School building Aid
I'm going to push her in the hot seats
you want to stay up for this one
I'm trying to run away he's trying to
escape
my page today
good morning
good morning still morning uh for the
record my name is Amy Clark and I'm with
the Department of Education I'm the
administrator for a program called
school facilities and uh building aid
program falls under my program I feel
like I've already gone through this
presentation with you yes uh so I won't
go Page by Page
um
I kind of had forgotten about that but
um real quickly
um just the handout here is probably
something you've seen before this is a
summary of our program and I'm really
here to answer any questions that you
have
answers I know and normally just
normally this might be more of a capital
presentation but I know that there are
funds in the general funds relative to
building a which is one of the reasons
why we thought it appropriate that we're
here
thank you Mr chair
um thank you it's always great to see
you and
um you know what really really really
would be helpful if you could um talk
about some of the building Aid bills
that we have um because we have I am I'm
putting you on the spot right no I'm
familiar with all of them I think so you
might be right he really is top-notch
um because um that would be helpful in
terms of our thinking and then again in
terms of thinking
you know our our public school districts
have gone for a long time with the
moratorium um and it's been tough on
many school districts and I know we've
heard from Michael Cahill
I hear from him every day
so we do too yeah
um so you know I I understand his lament
absolutely but um
one just one comment I am troubled by
the um capital budget items appearing in
the education trust fund so that that's
a comment I know she does not that's
that's a Governor's budget but if if you
could kind of allude to what it would
mean some of these bills I think it
would help all of us in our um thinking
because we're going to have to work on
this pretty soon so would um
if you could talk to some of those would
yeah right exactly so
um
so we're happy to come back and like
address a specific Bill and tell you
what our thoughts are I know that many
of these bills are over in education and
they're being as a policy debated there
so we're not sure we don't even know
what the education policy committee
wants to bring to finance at this point
in time so we don't want to get out over
our skis if that's possible I mean is
there a specific question you have
relative to a bill but I don't think
that we're prepared to kind of I don't
think you have them all memorized like
enumerated you know no I certainly could
talk about this graph a little bit which
would help you understand and read those
bills if that helps actually we we've
got we've got two or three bills
directly yes we already have
so you have you have three Finance bills
yes
um and so if you turn to this one with a
graph I think that no understanding this
graph will help you read through those
bills
um and that sounds good uh and so on
this graph just keep in mind that uh
there is a what we call a tail which is
those obligated funds for past projects
um in this graph that's that dark blue
bar but it's also the second column
there the so fiscal 24 says 20.6 million
dollars
um so then
um the light blue bar the one on top the
sits on top is the state Bond payment
that was taken out in 2010 uh and that
amount is for fiscal 24 is that 6.8
million
and then currently so if you add those
two together the two solid bars that's
27.4 you can see that's in the fourth
column of that table
right now I guess important to note that
currently in the law building it is Cap
at 50 million dollars
um that's the current that's what all
three of those bills kind of Target that
language so right now the maximum amount
of appropriation is 50 million less
these two solid bars so that's that one
two three the second to the last column
is 50 Min 50 million less are two
obligations one is to the state Bond
payment one is to pass projects that
would leave
22.6 million uh four new projects if the
maximum amount of was appropriated if
that ceiling was hit appropriated which
I believe is what is in
um the governor's budget right now uh
proposal so that is the 22.6 million
would be obligated for new projects uh
and that's how the law currently works
so now the bills proposed different
ceiling amounts in different ways of
creating a different fund for it
non-lapsing fund and so forth but that
essentially is in a nutshell what that
looks like thank you Mr chair we had a
wonderful conversation in the hallway
about
um what-ifs
um and uh in terms of building Aid if we
were to raise the um
the cap
um to 60 million
or to 70 million let's say if we raised
it to 70 million how many projects
would you be able to fund across our
state uh sure
um I think I knew you were going to ask
that question and I knew you could
answer our question on my phone rings a
lot once once uh Governor sununu
mentioned uh 75 million everyone and
wanted to know where that leaves them on
the list so if you go to page six again
if you look at the page numbers it's
this top right corner uh page six of 11
is the approved list
um and it really depends on the way the
bill is written because if it just
raises the cap that doesn't require
let's say it raises the cap to 60 it
doesn't require 60 million be
appropriated unless it changes it from a
minimum to a maximum which I know that
is under those bills as well so right
now it's a maximum of 50 million which
doesn't mean 50 million will be
appropriated but just the maximum I
think the bills all change that maximum
to a minimum so for example if it was a
minimum amount the top three projects
hit about the 49 million which is what
would be appropriated for new projects
across the biennium and so if you just
add those numbers up all the way through
you're going to get to see actually I'll
just let me so what you'll see is the
fourth ranked project is conquered for
70 million State contribution so
that would well um keep in mind um so
there's one thing that's really
important to note on this list this list
is their estimated project cost times
their building Aid rate that they
qualify for this is what they're asking
for it is very very important to know
that this isn't what they're eligible
for this is what they're asking for
they're simply it's a simple calculation
how much is their project times the rate
they qualify for is this estimated Aid
there's a little asterisk and it's hard
to see but it brings you all the way
back to the bottom of the table just
letting you know that this is just a
this is just what they are asking for so
um a good example is that Concord might
be asking for that amount of money but
if they're over building their facility
beyond the allowable specifications they
may not get all of that 70 million
and so but if they did then that that's
going to take you know an additional 70
million dollars to fund and it's hard to
um we're not quite through the review of
the next two projects those should be
done pretty soon
um and then we'll be on Project five
well right now we're on Project four of
reviewing it and then we'll we're
reviewing four and five at the same time
Mr chairman
thank you I'm going back to my thing
that if if a school district which
already has millions of dollars worth of
property
gives away
some property without a vote of the
people that own that property then they
should be discounted from getting money
from this you can't be giving away stuff
and then asking us to give you 70 or 28
million or 2.8 million or whatever when
you might have given away 2.8 million if
you gave away three buildings so
is that anywhere in there or do we have
to add it in the law depending on how
specific if you were to there is a
requirement that you pay building Aid
back if you're not using that facility
for intended purposes for 20 years so
within the first 20 years we're good
like they'd have to pay every every
penny back
um outside that window
um that's not clear in the law so that's
certainly essentially what the
commissioner said it's just a probably
an edit to the law that would be needed
thank you
I mean I think another important part
too is I mean if they sell a building
as if they receive proceeds outside of
the building a process right
we take those off the top before we
start to calculate the aid yes so if
they got a building and they sell it for
2.8 million dollars we're not going to
pay building Aid on that contribution
good
thank you so my question by the way uh
at some point we'll talk about
potentially different ways of funding
building Aid I'm sure but for now I'm
asking this question under the current
rules which are that we are paying you
know up front so only the first you know
projects that we have money for get
qualified
um
if for example we get you know let's
assume that for now the estimating
building Aid is what they'll be eligible
for just to keep things simple we all
understand that's not gonna be the case
so that brings us to pretty much you
know 50 50 or so million available to
450 or so million being spent with
pretty much neatly find the top three
projects so that would imply that if we
add 25 million that would make those
funds available but the next project
needs 70.
what happens if you know we say Okay
keeping the same formula not making any
changes we are offering Concord only 25
million that's all we have
for their project
you know what they have to vote and see
if the voters would approve building it
even with that limited amount of Aid or
will they wait two years to then
hopefully jump to the top of the line
what what how how do we handle those
situations in general I know that we
spoke in the past about you know voters
have to approve and if they don't
approve it and you get knocked on off
the list and the next in line gets to it
so that's why it's so hard to say right
now who's going to get funding because
there are a lot of variables but
what happens in a situation like this
where you have just a huge project
waiting right outside of what we have
currently funded that would basically
soak up every amount of dollars we could
possibly put in and you'd never get past
them anyway so under the current funding
formula how are under the current
um uh law it's a partial Grant they'd be
offered a partial Grant of whatever is
remaining whether that be 700 000 or 25
million dollars whatever was remaining
they'd offer it and they would be done
but there's no obligation to continue to
pay them across the biennium there is an
obligation between by any um between
year and one and year two we finished
paying off but once the biennium's
complete
um
they don't get any more money if they
reject that and say like well you're not
going to give us 70 you're only going to
give us 25 then and they say like no
we're not interested then we just take
the next one on the list this year but
next year presumably you know next
biennium presumably conquered to be
re-evaluated but because they were you
know at the top of the current pool
likely not many people will jump ahead
so that I'm trying to understand what
are the two years down the road Fourier
biennium you know Concord might be eight
on the list depending on who applies at
that point in time right the likelihood
of that that's a possibility you know
whether it's likely or not that's
unknown
um so there is a you know there like
Commissioners that there is a way to
jump It's a higher life safety points
and they jump over whoever's um however
um
in the past building Aid has been very
volatile so that it would be uh it's
hard to tell what any one school
district would do but there's never been
a promise for building a the next year
so that would be quite the risk to say
hey not 25 not only that construction
costs play a big role for schools to
wait
um but some schools would have to wait
because they can't fund their project
regardless they might not be able to
fund the project if they don't get all
of it
um or if they would not get voter
approval or I mean it's not
right and just for the record I I was
impressed by the approach that the
Concord school district is taking in
terms of setting money aside and trying
to flatten you know I mean that's
actually a commendable approach that I'd
like to see more of in the state so it's
just that again they need voter approval
you know voter approval is never
something that's easy to uh you know
figure out so
okay I think I understand this but
technically we could also have a
scenario where everybody gets about
three quarters of what they are asking
and then Concord doesn't get enough and
their voter is rejected and then we
would be finding a few more projects
down the line as funds become available
I'm good
continue
um well again I'm here for really your
questions I I think it's important to
note for those bills specifically um
what that graph looks like uh and it
also gives you an idea of where
um the numbers uh I think what's also
tricky if you actually look at the line
item in the budget
um it says for fiscal 24 it says it
probably says
44 uh 42.6 because what the the state
obligation isn't in there you won't see
an even 50 million on that line item you
won't see that even 50 million because
the the state Bond payment isn't in the
education trust fund line I know there
are these Treasures yeah but that state
Bond payment you know
um is is missing from there so it should
be
42.6 million
um for that first fiscal year anyway and
a little bit less for the next one or a
thank you so since we were talking about
you were mentioning earlier um you know
minimum and maximum spending the current
statute sets a cap of and there are uh
proposals that would set a floor of
given how many schools
projects we have that are already
reviewed and are considered eligible
is there any risk that if we don't set a
specific floor you won't spend every
dollar of building a that we are agree
you know approving for you given again
how big this pipeline is this in this
biennium I'm not talking about future
um can you repeat your question my
question let me rephrase it
I don't want to put you on the spot in
asking you know legislative questions
but does the department feel the need
that there is any
need for a floor to be set this year
given that we have such a long list of
building AIDS projects that are already
deemed eligible that would you know
ensure that any amount we allocate would
pretty much be spent to the max
so I think part of the problem with the
floor is again we don't know who is
going to take it or not take it so if we
right if if we can't get any takers on a
partial funding
then I can't get to the floor and so I
don't know who I'd give the money to at
that point well we have 17 projects and
three get funded but if somebody says
like if if nobody is like you know if
you have 700 000 left and I gotta spend
that 700 000 and nobody just wants 700
000 right so what do I get there so okay
I think so there's then if you gotta you
have to remember historically there has
been a More poem in place now since 2008
and so the longer we go without funding
a large quantity of projects the one the
more expensive projects get so one
project now might cost what three costs
in 2012 for example but the longer the
pipeline gets each year too so I think
we're going to continue to see the
pipeline grow each year and you have to
remember the Department of Education
accepts applications every other year in
July so the list that you have right
here is a school district's submitted
applications to assist Pastor Life Next
July you will have another list of
applications that have been submitted
and some of them may build with or
without building AIDS so they won't just
not be on the list and some will
continue to be on the list until there's
CE if it's provided or the school gets
so bad that on its own that nothing can
be done and they're going to have to
find a way to build thank you but I'm
just just one last follow-up I'm just
trying to understand whether setting of
would be productive because technically
we may end up with money that we are
legally obligated to spend in not one
place theoretically I'm not saying this
year again I agree that this biennium
you know we are going to have some
takers for every dollar we put I mean
it's just I'm trying to understand you
know
I offer you a half a million dollars I
may have everybody says like right no
we'll just we'll take our chances but
then what do we do if we have a floor
that we are obligated to spend right the
them just for I think when one of the
bills anywhere it says that it's a
non-lapsing fund so that money would
just carry over
um
I mean can I just one other thing
relative to this conversation on a
building that I think as the legislature
considers this is a little bit like our
security grants
um like what we have to do is like like
not have the up and the down like let's
just figure out a consistent kind of a
funding formula you know maybe it's a
per capita maybe it's something like
that maybe it just you know maybe it's
to each district on a per capita basis
and it just sets aside in a trust fund
over at the uh you know at the um
treasurer's office and when that that
district is ready to grab their their
piece of the trust fund they could do
something with it but just a different
approach because this and and uh I
expressed this but I think um you know
representative Flatt is on the committee
and some other individuals on the
building committee it doesn't feel like
a very efficient
diploma mechanism for deploying capital
for buildings it's kind of like who got
in line and when did they get in line
and stuff like that as opposed to a more
the three bills that we came directly to
finance which would retained are 541 332
and 546. if you want to comment on any
um I guess the only comment would be
that here is a here's what we here's
what it looks like now that cap is 50
million and just to Echo what the
commissioner said it's the if you look
back at this graph you can see the new
project spending is in that dashed line
it's like a little bit then nothing a
little bit nothing it is very difficult
for schools to plan for a construction
project without knowing what is
available or thus a steady stream of
funding or none at all right so so if if
um but it's almost like the carrot is
there sometimes and sometimes it's not
so I guess I'll just say it's difficult
for schools to plan without knowing if
money will be available or not
and not having non-lapsing fund so that
it grows when necessary
um thank you Mr chairman my thought as a
an attorney in drafting language that
would be appropriate to resolve the
concern about whether or not funding at
a floor could be met
um
you know in cases where those
communities don't make a voter approval
of the same expenditure you know these
are easily
drafted around you can create
conditional language to meet those you
know exceptions if the community doesn't
approve then the money could lapse I
mean you can you can build language that
will allow the intent of the Bill of
keeping a floor of expending to be
followed through in such a way that
doesn't require putting the state in a
bad position if voters don't approve of
those building Aid expenditures I'm just
saying you know I can think through
scenarios that
you know I'm sure many capable attorneys
across the state and you know supporting
the department of Ed could find a way to
meet the language that we need to meet
the intent of the bill to to have a
floor
um in the event that you know these
school systems and districts don't
approve of the
of you know the expenditure so my my
point is that this pipeline is so big
right now of these um
you know districts across across the
state looking for this funding that
um I I think the immediate concern of
whether or not you know it could be
problematic to have a floor is this is
kind of a
minor item I don't think we should get
caught up on that detail because I think
you know we could easily find a solution
to that concern in drafting language so
I just like to alleviate the concern
that I think we are expressing here so
we don't have to send the commissioner
and solve my problem there you go that's
where it goes and one last question
since I'm sure that this committee this
subcommit this committee and then the
larger finance committee will have a lot
of discussions about the proper
structure of this program right now the
questions that we asked were based on
its current you know structure but
obviously
there are a lot of thoughts on how we
could do better
do you does the department do you have
any thoughts in terms of you know if you
were a king for a day what would be an
optic optimal way of approaching
building aid for now notwithstanding the
current backup I understand the current
backlog is something that we are aware
of but just in long term how should this
work you know once we get a handle on it
you know
how should we do this long term in your
opinion at this point in time just
and then as we don't have all of the
incentives lined up
um you know so uh you know it's possible
that districts might because they're
getting a match be incentivized to build
a bigger School than they might need in
the long term because they can get 60 of
that cost from the state or something
like that so we have to get alignment
and so my thought around this is maybe
more of a sinking fund type of an
approach where the legislature is
funding a certain amount each district
that's going to have to build a school
every year it goes into some kind of a
trust fund over at the uh the
treasurer's office and you know like in
in one District's gonna say but we want
a new school now well they may not have
that much money in their trust fund at
that time but that's fine they can come
up with the rest of it and they've got
the incentive to to be as efficient as
they can somebody else says like I think
we can get a few more years out of it so
they get a little bit more State funds
build up in that trust fund and then
when they draw it down they get a little
bit bigger bigger State appropriation so
some type of a sinking fund type of an
approach so that we're not kind of in
this the application cycle and and um
is what I would basically uh suggest an
approach like that so
so I would just add to like the
sustainability of it is really important
because also what happens is that
schools
um potentially that are on the list see
that this is maybe a one-time
opportunity and they might not be
building the best project for their
Community because it might take them six
or more years to get there might take
them two or three it might take them a
fair amount of failed votes but
um if there was a dependability then I
think they would make smarter choices
because they wouldn't worry about
passing it right now while there's
building Aid available we're seeing the
same thing it's getting alignment you
know of objectives right
um is what we're trying to do create a
system that aligns those Community
objectives States objectives with the
school systems objectives as well
so it's kind of like an added building
adequacy a little bit right yeah but
syncing fun you can't do it use it it
doesn't get to go for anything else it
okay
representative
I just want to let the committee know
that house bill 452
is the bill that you don't have it's the
bill which looks from everything in
school moving aid from A to Z to A Whole
formula we will be discussing this in
policy and you're welcome to attend next
Friday at 9 30 in the morning all
morning it's dedicated just to the
school building a this is a bill which
we have to have out of committee by the
16th so in three days in three days
right when you say next Friday the
Friday this week not this week one week
yeah so we will be discussing that
because the topics that you're just
mentioning whether you get paid
this thing off as you go through the 20
years for whether you know if you lay it
on the district on the front side and
the interest costs and we're now looking
at that right now but we're looking at
if you decide you're not going to take
this money push it a fourth one in line
because I don't want half the money I
want the full money there's no guarantee
under your present form and you go to
the top of the list when the round is
considered again you may have another
project coming in higher higher need
that's going to bump you so all that's
going to be discussed
this is a huge issue it's something
um thank you
I think this question is probably
directed us to Amy
um if you were to pump punch the numbers
and try to determine the best strategy
for addressing the current need in the
pipeline
um moving forward in time so that we
don't continue to have this building a
pipeline
um that becomes so large that we can't
fund every project every year so I guess
the question is how how many projects
would we have to fund on a biennial
basis
to eliminate like this list of growing
schools who are kind of at the back end
of the list that don't get addressed
um is this question clear enough
um
so we anticipate you know there's how
many schools districts in the state and
every 20 years approximately I guess if
you are punching the numbers you know
how how could we
build a more sustainable program of
building Aid that addresses on a regular
schedule
meeting this pipeline so that it's not
such a huge list and I think this is
just like for planning purposes it would
be helpful to know as a committee you
know if the answer is we need to fund 10
projects every year so that every 25
years the first project that is funded
can have a new project and that
everybody else gets pumped through the
list so that I mean in an ideal setting
obviously this is we're talking a huge
budget if that were to happen but I
think he's not very happy that you're
happy no I guess yeah
do you want to talk about how you've
done some of that analysis and well just
let me guess real quickly I won't go
into all the detail but I mean really is
a somewhat simple math in the sense of
we have 450 school buildings we will
have less in the future there's a lot of
consolidation projects but just looking
at that and looking at the life of a
building before it needs a substantial
renovation is between 40 and 50 years
um and we're talking about substantial
Renovations so when we talk about
substantial we are talking about
um and if you think about your home and
you think about the abuse that school
takes a 50 year old building definitely
shows its age
um so using 50 and 450 only because
they're easy numbers it's nine schools a
year so 18 a biennium is probably what
you'd likely to see so as Caitlyn was
mentioning you know the the there's more
applications coming and we're likely
going to be adding 18 or so obviously
it's really difficult to say we meant we
had a moratorium for 10 years so there's
probably a backlog out there and I think
building eight right representative Vlad
was just mentioning Bill 4 52
um about
um changing the process so it's a little
easier for schools to apply for building
Aid time wise timeline wise
um and so I think that you would see a
fair amount of buildings be added to the
list can I just I'm going to clarify
that because I'm there's not necessarily
Universal agreement to the agency
relative to that because there are
variables that that doesn't consider you
know we're you know 46 000 fewer
students today than we were you know
when some of these buildings were built
and so they're in that queue of building
C do we need to rebuild them or do we
not need to rebuild them so there's that
Dimension the other dimension is the
level of Maintenance that's taking place
relative to a building I mean we have
buildings I think what's our oldest like
1930s
some buildings that have been highly
maintained are still very functional and
going you know they maybe need some
internal re redoing but maybe it's not
like a whole redo
um in terms of you know what's going to
take place in that building other
buildings have been built very
importantly and they're not going to
make it 20 years right like there's some
the windows are falling out after 10
years because they didn't put caulking
in the uh thing or something so there
again I so what happens is this is kind
of like this is what I was talking about
that top-down approach where we assumed
that we can kind of like manage all of
this is not synergistically going to get
be result in the capital deployment to
the right place it's going to be okay
I've waited long enough therefore I get
to build a new school well it might be
20 years later but if you don't need a
new school shouldn't we do something
else with that Capital should does
somebody else need one you know because
they had you know a different location
or something like that you know so so I
I worry
um when we try to over oversimplify
something that has uh you know quite a
number of dynamics that are moving in it
and so I think if you're searching for
another approach you know uh I like the
idea of we need something consistent you
know what I mean like there's a regular
type of funding towards this
um but I think we have to find something
that's more synergistic in terms of the
deployment of that capital I would I'm
just to say I would agree I mean that is
a very simplistic approach there's no
doubt that there's tons of variables
because a lot of the projects are not
full rebuild sometimes they're just an
addition sometimes they're just
renovating a certain Wing So I
completely agree that's really a very
very basic statement um that I was
making
um but I'd also um mention that another
thing to consider would be some kind of
assessment of all this that we've talked
about it before
an assessment of all the state of all
the buildings across the state and would
give a little bit more of an idea of
where we stood and where schools so so
for example if somebody if you had an
assessment and somebody applied for
building aid but they were way down that
doesn't mean they would get funded
because maybe we want to save that money
as a state to maybe Target it in
different places
chairman
thank you some years ago when Alec
meeting there was somebody from Arizona
worked in Department of Ed
brought up the fact that they had a
competition for
Architects to submit designs for a
a school building expandable say from
300 to 600
and since we're looking at likely 10
percent of the cost of the school is the
architect
so
they had a winner of the contest
then the
building Aid formula for Arizona here's
how much you can save using this design
and they said you'd use that design 38
times in Arizona saved a lot of money so
all these people that want to sit there
and argue and then you have Architects
that come very fanciful I'm not
satisfied with the one that was built in
Kingston
you know they had a lot of wasteful
space in it but
nobody made much of a decision so if we
had a real tough decision contest and
got a real good design
then that would be part of the offering
you want to build this school here
yeah so um at the department if this is
going back
um
pre-covered it might have been the 2018
time frame we worked with some uh design
build Finance types of organizations uh
that you know the school and and they
were packaging some tax breaks as well
um they would do kind of a build lease
back type of a program where if the
school district owned the land
um then they would actually build the
building
lease it to the school for 20 years at
less cost than the bond payment and then
give it back to the school at the end of
the 20 years
um hopefully it was in good shape at
that point but uh and so it was a net
cash flow advantage and they could do
this because there were certain tax
advantages associated with it the two
difficulties associated with that were
one um the financing was fairly complex
to explain to voters right to understand
what that might look like and the second
was that it also required you know it
was a modular approach to the schools
right so they had these different
components of schools and just like a
modular home or you know it's more
efficient and so you had to put it
together but to your point there
everybody was everybody had a uniqueness
right like my gym has to have this or my
Best of You has to look like this or
something like that so so we didn't get
a lot of
um we had a difficult time getting
traction and eventually the finance
company decided not to do it so
foreign
quick follow-up on the assessment of the
states because obviously we would
benefit from having a good understanding
of what the you know expected life
time is whatever we have left in them
and when a replacement uh may be needed
but would that be based on the current
number of schools or would it include
also an assessment of given the way the
student population is going
how many of those would need to be
replaced and how many of those wouldn't
and how many of those would benefit from
a consolidation you know I'm trying to
figure if we're just looking at the
facilities they are as they are or we
are trying to include and estimate at
that State level which may differ from
other municipality may want to do but
just our thought of what you know may be
necessary so I do actually want to
remind the committee that there you did
in House Bill 2 last year this was
something that Karen umberger found very
important was that you did actually
require the Department of Education to
do an assessment of all outstanding
current facilities
now the unfortunate part is is the
department hasn't been able to do that
work because the funding associated with
that assessment was not not provided but
that is so basically we would do an
assessment everybody would go out look
at the current facilities and whatnot as
far as an actual assessment of all of
the state needs that would be different
or potentially could be included if you
modify that existing law of course you
would still need to provide the funding
for the Department to do it so
thank you
yes
and we worked with Amy Clark in doing
the country lend out and and then we
came up with that Project based upon
what it costs to assess a building with
an architect uh with an engineer and
with policy people and having the same
consistent people going out to all the
schools in the state by where we are in
terms of condition uh and all the
different areas which we want to look at
from classroom condition curriculum to
space available for a special education
Etc and uh we were ready to go ahead
with that this this idea has been
proposed to us for years even going back
to Days of Mark Joyce and um each time
we and we had a very good bill reason
why I didn't go anywhere because you
guys didn't fund it 3.3 million dollars
those Finance people
but the fortunate thing is we took that
money and used for public school
interest
infrastructurity and access which is
okay could you for one more time for the
people at home and me because I want to
okay that's how good my memory is
okay
anything else
no we can uh if you want to take a break
we can do that but then we're going to
Pivot into adequacy adequacy the
question is do you want to take a quick
lunch break we're going to go through
the governor's proposal in detail and
I'm guessing it will likely take an hour
so if you want to take a lunch or if you
want to try to rush through it right now
so that you can I'd rather take lunch
snow in your commute home and affecting
itself
so if there's nothing else Let's uh take
a lunch break until one o'clock just
because it's easier than saying ten to
one
okay
sure thank you
Mike's Hot
um so as I had heard the governor's
presentation on on building Aid and he
had put in 75 million dollars and I
listened to several of the bills that
were introduced to the full committee I
realized
that we have an ongoing issue on how we
do building Aid we have 20 school
districts that are looking for help and
even if we funded it at the 75 million
dollars as requested by our governor
we would cover Concord we would get one
more on the list we would go from three
facilities to four that are funded in 16
schools would still end up with a short
straw
so I started rethinking about this in
light of some of the other comments made
by members of Finance is there a better
way to do this
and and every child needs some classroom
to learn in
we homeschool we have a dedicated office
space that is our space for children but
we fund it as parents but it's I'm not
saying that because I'm looking for the
state to contribute but we dedicated
physical space for for for learning to
take place
that's true for all public schools
that's true for our Charter Schools it's
true for everybody there is some spaces
that that the education takes place in
if we took that same 75 million dollars
and allocated it differently you could
fund the K-8 students at 450 a child per
year
to help offset costs
you could fund the high school students
at 500 a year then that if you do the
math for the 110 000 Keith rate students
that works to 49.5 million dollars to 53
000 high school students who works out
to twenty six and a half million for a
total of 20 76 million dollars or very
close to what the governor had had
recommended
part of the rationale for the higher
costs for the high school level students
are you have additional lab space you
have votech classroom space so you have
other things that are that are not just
typically lunchrooms recess areas and
education space right you have you have
facilities that are that are a higher
cost to build and a higher cost to
maintain
heck for even some of the some of the
high schools have Auto Repair type
facilities all of those extra tools
space extra areas require additional
funds to run on an annual basis
if we instead of funding buildings we
funded the classroom space where the
education takes place in and we thought
about it not as building aid but make
sure make sure every child has access to
a space to learn in
we could reallocate this
in a semi-permanent or maybe even
long-term permanent space to augment the
current swept funds that go down to the
children
to help facilitate classroom space
right and
um
this would go directly to the towns
right it's whether it's for use for a
capital reserve fund to plan for a new
building whether it's for use for major
Renovations
um major repairs right the the roof fell
in we need to do something
for temporary rented classrooms for for
lease space for rented space right this
would not be used for keeping the the
grounds taken care of and
um doing the regular HVAC maintenance of
replacing filters that's not what the
intent would be the intent would be
capital reserve level funding for the
different schools that they could use
long term and how they would use it
would be either hey we're going we need
three mobile classrooms in here we have
a peak going through this Elementary
School and we see that we're going to
have a need for an extra 35 students for
the next couple of years but then it
goes away our population has that bubble
running through that and because our
school can't handle that bubble this
year we need to to deal with that with
mobile classrooms
by allowing it to follow the child at
some level and to be allocated uniformly
you would get a chance to um
start making sure schools can budget for
this and it would encourage better
behavior in terms of planning long term
they know that they're going to have
this much money available to do capital
reserve level projects so I'm willing to
draft up an amendment the bill that
looked like the most applicable one
would be 332 but there might be another
bill that's coming through relative to
education building Aid that might be the
right vehicle to have this discussion
and I'll go get a formal Amendment
drafted for that I just wanted to
introduce the topic because I think
there is a way to better use the money
and not necessarily end up with the
winners and losers that we do every year
the problem is everybody puts in these
huge grants and these applications that
are hundreds of pages thick and then the
voters don't know whether they're going
to get it or not when they go to the
town meetings the system is fraught with
problems
where if they knew that they were going
to get X dollars per child to use for
childhood space or for classroom space
they could plan on it and budget around
it and empower the local school boards
to do the right thing so that's the the
the quote sales pitch unquote on the
idea and the discussion I'm willing to
draft work on drafting an amendment to
this committee I just need some some
Bill that makes sense to do something
like this very Senate flag
just came in the last part of this
discussion
two is a Bill dealing with the
application process for school building
Aid and it goes from A to Z which has
been cracked very closely with
Department of Education
so this is a different idea it's a
different idea okay
all right could I ask a question please
sure
um thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
um just let me rephrase what I think I
heard you said absolutely sure so what I
believe I heard you say was that um the
intent of the amendment that you are
going to prepare is to eliminate
building Aid as we know it now and
instead
using the adequacy per child process you
would assign
um four hundred dollars to K through 8
and 500 for high school students
on an annual basis is that so yes very
very close so I think the number was 450
K through 8 and 500 for
um high school and it wouldn't be just
adequacy it would be a separate program
running in parallel much handled much
like adequacy is today but it would be
some
facility payment Reserve payment or I'm
not sure what the proper term another
one of the little boxes it would be a
little box but it's uniform across the
state it's per child to make sure that
there's there's room for classroom space
we all know that someone needs to have a
place to learn right although I mean you
theoretically could learn at the town
library if you're homeschooling there is
some facility payment necessary and some
of this is for maybe it's an expansion
maybe it's a roof renovation to keep the
facility running or maybe it's putting
it in the capital reserve fund to plan
for the building because we know we're
gonna have to do something about it we
see a bump in population because our
town is growing a follow-up please so
adequacy dollars for example the
educating Freedom accounts um
where they would get this too I'm
presuming I don't know if it would
um that that's up to this committee or
the subcommittee right
no I see this I I currently see this for
the public school and charter school
students right this this is for the
buildings right as opposed to for The
Homeschool students right I but then
again personally I'm I'm wired so
although we might have been eligible for
at least one year during the various
um education Freedom savings account
type stuff we didn't participate right
we would we funded our own so I see this
more for the 161 000 students that are
currently in the public school system
nope
thank you nice seeing you Jr
uh representative jails
um who would be the agents to expend in
this special fund and and and answer
that question and I got a follow-up okay
so I don't know whether it would be
overseen by the doe it's not real clear
how we would do this or or potentially
dra or Das in terms of write somebody to
administer it I think we would want to
have a fund created that's some sort of
capital fund and then we transfer the
payments from there to the local towns
when they have a capital need and the
capital need could be as simple as the
school board says hey we want to just
um we want 100 of the funds eligible to
us to come to our capital reserve
account we've had a capital reserve
account for years we want to continue to
grow it that's where it goes boom it's
done it might be another school saying
we don't have a capital reserve fund but
we just had a major leak to the roof it
was unanticipated and I now have a 75
000 repair that I've got to start
thinking about we want to apply to that
right and follow-up to that uh I'm on
the trustee the trust funds in my town
and I oversee the capital reserve
accounts which we have one for the
school for building Aid of building you
know building grounds I believe we call
it and what we do we put maybe twenty
thousand dollars a year and we we just
went through that whole process and put
on two new roofs on our two of our
buildings and you know and it's worked
out great it's not such an impact to the
but we have to think about who that
agents to expend is and so it's not done
frivolously matter of fact I think we
have one bill at two and a half percent
if you remember you know that the the
districts can hold back yep you know I
remember that okay so maybe on the lines
you know you can spend these are the
some of the items that you can spend it
for what I was trying to avoid is this
just ends up at the school board level
and offsets the total budget because it
gets pushed into the the annual
facilities so capital reserve accounts
are a great place to push the money to
because that that's managed slightly
differently than putting into the
operating budget that handles the
landscaping and in the routine
maintenance of the building right well
some with if I may follow up on that
some of the funds are the legislative
body in other words the the on a Town
warrant or a school district warrant yep
and have it so it can be released that
way of course you might have emergency
which then maybe you have to hold the
public hearing
you know to to be able to expend the
funds which sometimes that's too easy
because nobody shows up to public
hearing even though it's 18 millions of
dollars in both cases though whether
it's done in a town meeting or done
through an emergency school board
meeting right if you're truly talking
about making sure that the facility is
being taken care of to allow the
education to take place then then you're
serving the needs without the current
system of picking winners and losers
right the problem with today's system is
everybody wants to be the the lottery
winner by putting together this great
application and then at the end of the
day they have expended lots of time and
resources and Engineering hours and
architect hours to put together this
this
maybe small six-page proposal in terms
of the executive summary but hundreds of
pages worth of additional documentation
and then they don't get it and now what
do they do the voters are in this
quandary so I was looking at on the list
of proposed building AIDS
um lines four and five Concord is next
in line they want 176 Million Dollar
middle school for 900 students
and their ask is 70 million dollars
worth of building eight and then
Litchfield is right behind that
Litchfield wants to build a school
roughly half the size for 32 million
dollars which is a much lower cost per
student the smaller School building as
well one was 212 000 square feet one was
000 square feet so roughly a third the
size for a population that's about half
as big and then they're only asking for
10 million dollars so how does the state
start reviewing these yes there's a long
review process but I'm not sure it
serves the citizens well for the entire
state it would be better off if we
started funding and said you can plan on
this money coming into some capital
reserve account you guys be good
stewards at the local level of how you
administer these accounts
and uh
to your point earlier capital reserve
accounts are managed differently in
within different towns
um we in Dunbarton every year we put
money in the capital reserve account and
and that has covered the major roof
repairs and the redo of the HVAC system
to to better equipped it to handle right
overall Heating and and started to chip
away at the cost when we needed to add
four additional classrooms
so I think
this encourages towns to be wise with
how they spend their money to manage
their infrastructure so that they can
educate the children and that isn't that
the purpose of building Aid in the
broadest possible sense as opposed to
the current system of I got the lucky
architect who wrote the better proposal
who managed to get us to the top of the
list and we don't need the grant writers
and we don't need a lot of the other
things that go along
if the town knew in March that they were
going to get
um
let's say a hundred thousand dollars in
in aid from the state on for their
budget then they could plan for that and
put it in the capital reserve and write
the warrant articles so it's it's a
long-term thing to change how we do this
but I think it would be better it would
help towns better manage their schools
they could figure out whether they want
to put money toward repairing something
or planning for an addition or building
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um you are suggesting a you know forward
change that would be you know maybe
better in the long term right but that
still leaves us with you know an
existing backlog of projects and people
who have gone through the application
process and whatnot what are your
thoughts in terms of just transitioning
assuming that this is the direction we
want to go into long term but how do we
handle the current you know so there is
a backlog and I don't have the numbers
in front of me but I wanted to say it
was north of 200 million dollars or some
yeah worth of requests from the state
one one only one school of which was
which was close to a third of that total
amount
um what about the schools that didn't
make the lists right they so so
we need to make sure that there are
facilities for all the children within
the state and the best way to do that is
to encourage local school boards to be
wise about how they spend their money
and maybe it's Elise right maybe it's a
maybe it's some mobile classrooms right
not a fan of mobile classrooms I get it
they're they're less than ideal places
to to educate but maybe it's it's that a
mobile classroom is the right solution
because they know that their population
is pretty level and they have a bubble
just because of who moved into town
several years ago so I would like to
encourage local school boards to be very
efficient in how they use their money
and to be why stewards of the buildings
that they have and this helps them make
those decisions if they know that this
money's coming as opposed to I wrote a
grant I waited a year plus 18 months in
other cases before I knew and how does
the town plan for that which which
particular budget meeting are you going
to bring this up you start the proposal
but you have no idea when the voters
come in March they may not even know
that they're gonna this is going to come
to fruition because it's tied to
legislation at some level or it could
change the system's broken so the way to
fix a broken system in some cases is to
not try and repair and vanity the system
anymore it's to go forward with
something that would be a prudent way to
fund the space that people need long
term
thank you
well I I can't answer your question
right now about which which of the many
we have but I would recommend House Bill
too so the 75 million dollar
appropriation will be in House Bill too
it could go into thank you uh I was
thinking
I said I wouldn't recommend a specific
bill because these are going to end up
in hb2 okay my thought was of the bills
that I saw 332 was the one that I was
going to if you guys wanted to exec that
one out I was going to draft the
amendment to 332. it was germane to the
bill it's a it's a complete replace but
um but we could just add we can put it
in hb2 I get it for the purpose of
having a conversation right it's a
paradigm shift and Paradigm shifts take
time for people to understand it's not
easy to just say well but it's always
worked this way well it hasn't always
worked this way how many schools are
still on the waiting list for 16 schools
still on the waiting list trying to to
do new buildings
um and then we end up with these
projects that are Ultra expensive
because they're going to get some free
money from the state
yes I just want to talk a little bit
about building Aid
um building Aid has been in place for a
long time but we also had a 10-year
moratorium we did not have any building
aid for 10 years because we have the
tail and we have to pay up the tail
um there is a very
thorough process that the department of
Ed goes through in terms of of building
Aid a building the life of a building
should be 40 years and we probably have
500 school buildings in the state of New
Hampshire
um and some have gone through building
Aid usually
in the normal practice
there was a process where a town would
work on passing a bond and then they'd
get their building Aid
um and the moratorium halted that so
that has created a problem now
we had a moratorium for 10 years now we
are flush with cash right now we as I
said earlier we are blessed in New
Hampshire we have so many much funding
and we've never had a surplus in the
education trust before to this extent
right so my fear is
all of a sudden you're proposing a new
methodology
it really hasn't been vetted
um hasn't really been heard from the
public
um we haven't I mean we're talking about
it right now but I just get a little bit
nervous when I start thinking about
putting something of this magnitude into
hb2
um without having some kind of a public
response
some kind of a public hearing
because we have not had that you are
bringing up now earlier in this day
um the commissioner of Education was
here and he had a very similar proposal
to what you were talking about
um in that money would be put in with
the treasurer and it would be held
um in an account and then districts
could kind of draw down on I think
that's kind of what his okay it was very
similar to what you're proposing
actually
um so this is just it's such a new way
of thinking about something wouldn't it
be better to go through a different
process and get some public feedback
it's a great point and and maybe the
right thing to do is call it an a
non-germain I'll put it in quotes
non-germaine amendment to HB 332 bring
it back up for a meeting schedule it in
the calendar have a meeting on it so
that everybody's notified
uh
Dunbarton and I'm going to use our local
town has historically been very good
about budgeting right
um and with the minor
um minor Financial Accounting
um
error that was when we were part of
gosstown along with
um what wasn't new it wasn't New Boston
right other than that accounting era
that racked up 14 million dollars in
excess funds that should have been
returned and what to do with those we've
been really prudent about how money has
been spent locally and it's it's worked
right the the town plans for these
things we plan for our roads we've been
budgeting money every year in terms of
capital we put a hundred thousand
dollars every year into the capital
reserve to help keep the roads going and
whatever
I do the same thing personally I think
about the car right I'm going to have to
buy a car at some point I like buying
cars and cash it makes it the
negotiations a whole lot easier
and when you do that you can go into the
dealer and say this is what I want to
pay here's the check and when you start
walking out about 10 steps outside the
front door they tend to call you back in
and say I'll sell you the car
because you can you can negotiate a
really good price if you're trying to
negotiate on the lease terms it's not as
good a way to negotiate I think
unfortunately we've incentivized how
much can you borrow how big a building
can you build because we're going to
give you 30 percent of this in some
cases and sixty percent in others and it
encourages behavior that is less than
being prudent and prudent stewards of
the money I think there's a better way
to do this because if they knew they
could count on it which is the problem
the moratorium created right over the
years
um and they don't know if they're going
to get the money if your number five six
seven on the list do you count on it I I
don't know and yes we're flush with cash
reserves right now because the
businesses have done exceedingly well
over the last couple years and and the
revenues have come in much higher than
predicted we cut the taxes everybody
said hey move move Revenue into New
Hampshire it's a friendly place to do
business now and when an accountant in
New York says well we can call it in in
this division in New Hampshire it's a
good place to bring Revenue in guess
what it happened in no surprise when you
have low tax status people try and move
their their company Revenue under those
low tax umbrellas so I'm not surprised
that we we saw the additional Revenue
maybe there needs to be a step
transition but I'm I'm looking at this
is the long term the right thing to do
is to help talents plan well in advance
and if they knew that they could count
on this they could start putting it into
the capital reserve year after year
after year and that way when they need
to go do a building or put something in
place they have the money to do it and
in terms of legislation why not have a
hearing on this call it a non-germain
Amendment if we need to we can put it
into the calendar for this week and have
this discussion so everybody's invited I
I have no it's not about trying to hide
a different process it's the Paradigm
that we have today is broken and when
you start talking about a new paradigm
it takes a lot of work
but I want to I want to have that
conversation I want to have that
dialogue out in the open because I think
long term this could be beneficial to
all the students in the state not just
the select few that happen to be the
winners in the current in the current
building aid process I have a suggestion
how it might work
because the governor has has
recommended or budgeted an additional 25
million to the 50 that's been kind of
like the standard yep and in discussions
with prior members of this committee I
said where'd the 50 million come from
and the answer was well I thought that's
what we could get past
so I mean it's not like it's a magic
number
is to continue the current process
budgeted at 50 million
take the 25 million and do it on an
allocation basis
for
two
I don't know how many cycles I'm just
right okay now so the 25 million starts
setting up this fund
for per student right like building
adequacy I mean if we want to create
something well it's still it's
facilitated it's in the broadest term
right you've got 25 million now going to
that fund as
we continue the same broken system
because it's an ugly baby but it's ours
right so you know
I don't think it's right just to cut it
off
but if we can transition out of it right
with these additional funds it might be
a way to do it okay
I like the concept how would you defend
the figures you've chosen 450 and 500 if
somebody challenged you one that's not
enough for what good is that or
those are great questions I took the 75
million dollars that had been allocated
in hb2 as the round number looked at the
170 sorry 161 000 public school students
and said that works out the 485 per
child we do know we do per year per
child we do know that
um that it's easier and less costly to
build infrastructure for elementary
schools than it is middle schools and
middle schools is less costly than high
schools so I I we didn't have I started
asking questions about middle schools
there's not a real clear definition of
is Middle School seven and eight six
seven and AI I was on education for
years I don't know what in New Hampshire
where we draw that line so we have k
through eight in one bucket in high
school
um and I just did the math to try and
simplify how we get to the 75 million
dollars and the math worked out the 76
million in terms of reasonable now round
numbers so if we took my thought it's
one third of this you take one third of
well thank you I think I I think if you
want to put something together more
formally because it's going to take some
more thought process you've heard our
questions sure uh is HP 32 the right
bill then that was the one that looked
like it was a possible one in terms of a
fit on on just straight
um
right it's relative to school building
age projects and
um this was trying to allocate an extra
five hundred thousand dollars and right
sorry five million dollars per year
um
whether we tack it on to that whether we
do a repeal and replace but
um that that bill I think was going to
be retained by your committee so it has
been okay
I don't know the procedural part of this
Nick could you shed some light if the
committee was gonna
go down the path of changing any sort of
aid program or appropriating money I'd
say at this point House Bill one and two
are your vehicles to do that so while
House Bill 332 is set to be retained
that was our initial recommendation on
that uh if you're gonna have spending I
would say if it's part of your budget
package one and two would make the most
sense so a house bill two Amendment for
this would so do we have to have a
special is the right thing to do to have
a hearing on it that's a question of the
clerk germaneness is pretty broad when
it comes to House Bill one and two
especially since we already have school
building Aid uh included in the budget
as well as changes to school building
Aid would that Fund in House Bill 2 you
may not need
the hearing um but let's have a hearing
on it I mean the benefit there is right
not that I want to have everybody take
an extra 20 minutes or half an hour hour
but at least in terms of openness and
honesty and transparency yeah we can
have a hearing yeah
sure
the one thing I'll say is you'll need an
amendment drafted before it can be
noticed so okay that's going to put us
out
until the just to put that out there so
um since you're having discussions on on
education related things do we do a
draft amendment to that section of hb2
hb2 hasn't even come over yet so it's
hard to do an amendment to it something
we haven't seen but I'll ask
um our our side maybe I can speak with
you afterward have you draft up the
amendment for this and then I'll present
it in a at whenever you can schedule
something
and um
referring to our workload
we're two weeks roughly tomorrow into
the six weeks we have and we're two
weeks behind
we didn't start off with Ways and Means
estimate we still haven't got hb2
we're going to have four weeks left to
do all our work so
for your chairs and vice chairs
plan on five days a week at least
and probably later days
I don't want to be the bearer of bad
news but it's three weeks not four so
with three weeks from Thursday is our is
our plan drop dead division deadline for
uh decisions the 23rd
Mr chair I'd just like to take a moment
to recognize how truly rushed that feels
for a major change in our Educational
Funding system so I I would just like to
think that if we were to honor this idea
and truly vet it for not only the
upsides that we're talking about now but
potentially vetting these down potential
downsides that we haven't even begun to
discover
um that three weeks is probably not
enough time to to really go through that
process and I I would just like to pump
the brakes on behalf of the rest of the
Granite Staters who are not represented
in this room I think I think this may be
a rush to a really great idea down the
road but I'm feeling like three weeks is
not gonna do it justice well part of our
retaining these bills is to make
recommendations for the next legislative
cycle so it's probably a good idea to do
this next to legislative cycle if we
only got three weeks left I don't
and we got 52 bills collectively right
foreign
don't mean to interrupt thank you Mr
chair we've just come off a 10-year
moratorium school districts are
scrambling
um all of a sudden cities were hopeful
about moving forward they were beginning
to think again that there was going to
be more building Aid available and now
all of a sudden to do a complete about
face to something completely different
I mean I just
as a former used to be in Dunbarton too
by the way
um
you know I I just think it's too much to
ask of people in this short a window you
know I think people need more time to
absorb something of this magnitude and
really to get some feedback I'd like to
hear from the superintendents so from
education
um
I agree you know it's too much too fast
too soon
it's a good idea thank you next term
next term it is interesting
just as a quick thought
I completely agree with the previous
remarks that it's kind of hard to turn
this boat in three weeks
but
I am reminded of what somebody was
telling me that in preparing for major
changes it is good to make a send a
clear signal to people that changes are
coming so they can start preparing and
maybe just retaining a bill with a plan
to do something about it next year may
not be enough of a signal I just was
gonna suggest that maybe the committee
would consider a
the reasonably small amount of money you
know a million or two or three just to
create a placeholder in terms of you
know signaling to the towns that the
current model is approaching its end of
life and they need to start planning
differently you know I think the
objections would be much less
significant in terms of oh my God this
is rushed if we would only touch a small
part of the money and leave the bulk of
it as it is I just wanted to put this on
you know for the committee to consider
at a lower level
get the idea out there
well thank you Jr welcome
yeah yeah thank you Mr chairman uh one
of the things we've been working on this
since 2011 because that's why the
moratorium is put in place we we've been
putting this off and putting this off
and putting us off and matter of fact
there's several of us here that uh have
seen that happen and we we need to we
need to get off you know get something
done because uh we keep putting it off
and the more you keep putting it off the
yes
this is a huge topic
and we've been looking at it in
education policy and we provided
information before I'm looking right now
in the state of Montana
okay
the state of Montana went through this
process and in HP one they allocated 2.5
million dollars uh for the condition
assessment to conduct a K-12 Public
Schools facility condition assessment of
all schools in their state so they knew
what they were dealing with just as
starters they looked at facility
condition they looked at energy use they
looked at educational characteristics
and they looked at technological
infrastructure within the schools
I'd like to remind you that 50 of the
school buildings in New Hampshire are
over 60 years old
six percent built prior to 1900.
26 percent built prior to 1950. seven
schools over 60 years old have not had a
major renovation in more than 50 years
196 schools that 60 percent originally
built 50 plus years ago
15 percent of schools are using portable
classrooms
so we have some real situations out
there in our state here which need
address
and if we're going to start thinking
well we're going to fund X number
dollars per pupil
then we gotta consider the
characteristics of what a middle school
is I heard k through eight no middle
schools are grades four through eight
and sometimes nine
so the structure from one place in a
state to another place in the state are
very different
and would that go the cost for
elementary middle and high school
instruction and curriculum and delivery
of services
when we put this formula we have in
place now and it's not perfect
but we had a working group which
involved folks from other states as well
my in fact my old athletic director who
was who was the commissioner of
education for the state of Maine came
over and explained their uh process for
building Aid there's a lot of different
ways to do it you look any education
Commission in States and they will
provide you that information I got that
report just yesterday and so I would
suggest that anything you're planning to
do
don't go over the deep edge
work with policy and let's do this thing
properly so we don't go down the rabbit
hole and end up I'll figure how we're
going to get out of it
thank you
Mickey should have already passed this
I've got some other uh longer
spreadsheets
uh
three
I feel like whenever I do an adequacy uh
spreadsheet it's just a fight with the
printer and I always lose and um the
so for the record Mark Manganiello
Department of Education Bureau of school
Finance
so I know I was here uh last month it
seemed seemed like longer than that
um
uh
going over the 2024 District adequacy
formula so in this packet not looking at
the Town by Town we're going to be going
through this packet the first page is
your 2024 current Law formula so I know
we discussed this
um last month but we'll just go over it
kind of briefly just so you under
remember the structure of the adequacy
formula that document page two the
fiscal year 24 formula
so
the way the formula works it's highly
driven by student data so each student
is 18 ADM an average daily membership
it's how we measure a student's
membership within a school district for
a full year so we're using adms student
accounts whatever you want to call it
the technical term is ADM but each ADM
is
3866.18 so that is your base aid for
each ADM students educate or towns have
more than one student typically so it's
usually one time or you know 10 students
times there are 20 students or a
thousand students or if you're
Manchester over ten thousand students uh
per
3866 dollars and eighteen cents that
gets you your base adequacy Aid amount
then we look at other demographic
information about that student we look
at if they are experiencing poverty
meaning they are below 185 percent of
the federal poverty guidelines so they
are eligible for the free and reduced
price meals program within their school
district and if they're eligible
eligible for that program sometimes
we'll say fnr fnr student we add in
addition to base adequacy we add the one
thousand nine thousand one thousand nine
hundred thirty three dollars and eight
cents for each one of those students we
also look for other demographic
information about that student we look
if they have receiving IEP services and
they're a sped student and we add
2079.89 to the cost of an adequate
education calculation as we go through
these metrics uh moving forward English
language Learners if they are an English
language learner we had
756.43
to the cost of an adequate education
calculation
um last one is third grade reading third
grade reading is if they score below
proficient on the third grade reading
test
um are in third grade and are not f r
eligible are not receiving sped Services
nor are they an English language learner
so for there any one of those categories
they are excluded from that Aid
um and the score below proficient on the
third grade reading test we give
756.43 for that student and so I have
another document that will they'll
explain this but that is typically
called the left side of the formula
because we work the formula left to
right that is the first part of the
formula so we call that the left side of
the formula sometimes we call that the
Constitutional side of the formula
because it's linked back to RSA 193 uh e
so we're telling up all those metrics
and we're getting the cost of an
adequate education the cost of an
adequate education is uh what the state
has has determined is what is necessary
for you to provide the opportunity for
an adequate education according to state
law so if we tally up all those metrics
um we get a number we tally up the base
base a time all the different adms F and
R times all the all the adms in the
community
and so if we tally that all up we might
get a cost of an adequate education of a
million dollars
if we get a cost of an adequate
education of a million dollars
um the state is obligated to ensure that
you have a million dollars to provide
that opportunity of an adequate
education but before we cut a check for
a million dollars we look to see what
your swept is and so if a community
raised five hundred thousand dollars
through their swept tax the Statewide
education property tax the state would
cut a check for 500 000 so they have
five hundred thousand dollars in swept
which I sometimes call a swept Grant
um then they also have 500 000 in
sometimes called an adequacy Grant so in
total they have the million dollars
therefore they have the money necessary
to provide that adequate education as
defined by the state
then there's these that's that's most
communities most communities the cost of
an adequate education is greater than
their swept but then there's some
communities that are called excess swept
communities
um uh those communities the cost of
inadequate education could be a million
dollars the swept brought in could be
two million dollars therefore they have
excess swept of one million dollars
because they have one million dollars
over an adequate education
um
uh
that uh over uh over 10 years ago there
used to be a law in place that if you
had excess swept you had to remit that
to the state
um those were called
um those communities said we are donor
towns and they advocated for not having
that regime in place so that regime has
not existed for over 10 years
um so now if you have two million
dollars in swept and the cost of an
adequate education of a million dollars
um you don't remit anything to the state
you keep all two million dollars locally
your municipality sends it all to your
school district and so the swept grant
for that Community would be two million
dollars
so it's just important to remember what
excess swept is because it interacts
with the funding formula the way you see
the math kind of shake out and so that
is essentially the left side of the
formula we're talking about now there's
something called the right side of the
formula which this is Aid that is above
and beyond the cost of an adequate
education
and so you might uh I know we talked
about this last month but relief aid
grant that is a Statewide 17.5 million
dollar Grant it's based on the
percentage of f r population within your
community
so if you have a f r percentage above 12
percent or for under 12 you don't get
you're not eligible for Relief aid over
12 percent you start off at receiving
150 dollars for each fnr student
um and then it kind of escalates up to a
maximum Grant it's a sliding scale basis
of 600 per each fnr student
um if your fnr percentage within your
community is 48 or above
um so and that Grant is prorated up or
down to be 17.5 million each wide uh
Statewide so we do the calculation and
then we do we back into that 17.5
Million number or back up back down into
that number to make sure the grant is uh
exactly 17.5 million
the extraordinary needs Grant is a new
Grant uh starting this fiscal year and
that Grant is based on
property values over F and R counts so
property values over poverty counts and
so if you have it's think of it as a
fraction you have the numerator is
property the denominators uh poverty
counts so if you have a lot of property
and not a lot of students experiencing
poverty you would receive a high number
if you have a low tax base and a lot of
students in poverty you would have a low
number so when we do that metric we I
think we call the acronym
evpfr so it's equalized valuation per
each fnr pupil I don't think we've
settled on unofficial acronym yet
um
it's a yeah maybe you can write more you
can write in and you can write the
acronym in law if you'd like uh so
so if it's six million dollars or
if your EV FRP your property value is
over F and our accounts is six million
or higher meaning kind of two things
either one you have a company
substantial tax base or two you don't
have a lot of students experiencing
poverty or a combination of the two so
if it's over six million dollars
um you do not receive an extraordinary
needs Grant if it's a million dollars or
under you receive a grant of six hundred
and fifty dollars for each fnr student
and so that Grant Works similar to
relief Aid it's escalating it's a
sliding scale Grant so your Grant is
going to start at 650 if you're at that
one million EV FRP number and it's going
to slowly decrease on a sliding scale
basis to eventually get to zero once you
get up to six million
so there's no fiscal Clips in that Grant
or the relief Aid Grant and then
um the next Grant which is um on the
right side of the formula is the
stabilization Grant or the stabilization
Grant is due to changes in the funding
formula during 2012. so there's changes
in the funding formula following the
Great Recession
um I don't know some of the people in
the room can talk about the Great
Recession and how that was a tough
budget year but there was changes to the
funding formula that resulted in uh uh
the changes to the formula resulted in
some communities receiving less money
and so what the legislature decided to
do is hold them harmless to what they
received in 2011. so no Community
received less money than what they see
received the previous year and in total
that cost the state 158 million dollars
to build this stabilization Grant and so
that's from 2012 is when it was enacted
so it was based on changes in the
formula from 2011 to 2012. it still
exists today uh there's been some
legislative history to try to have it
phase out but then it was recently
restored to the full amount in fiscal
year 2020. so right now Statewide that
is around 157 million because some
communities of lost their eligibility
because they um are now in excess swept
town if you become an access webtown
you're not eligible for the
stabilization Grant
um so Statewide that Grant is 157
million uh
and that is the 24 current Formula so
before I go on to the governor's formula
do we have any questions about current
law yes so the the stabilization is the
same amount of money regardless of your
population correct it's a static Grant
that's a good question that comes up all
okay
okay uh new stuff so
so this is this is a table and it kind
of I'll walk you through the table
there's you can see at the top top left
hand side left side there's the left
side of the formula and so the left side
of the formula like I talked about is
base Aid and then it's called
differential Aid which is basically the
fnr raid the sped eight or I'm on page
three of the the handout
um base Aid so there's that three three
thousand eight hundred and sixty six
dollars and 18 cents
um fnr raid sped Aid ell Aid third grade
reading aid that's the left side of the
formula
then we have swept Grant in the middle
and then on the right side we have the
right side of the formula and so
I've added two more Dimensions to this
because there's three different adequacy
programs I I just walked you through the
district public adequacy program but we
also have Charter adequacy and we also
have EFA adequacy so this is showing you
all all three adequacy programs there
and it's showing you how they sync up
with the left side of the formula and
how they sync up with the right side of
the formula so on the right side of the
formula we also have something called an
additional grant
that is only about if you look kind of
at the middle columns there Charter
adequacy the additional Grant only
applies to Charter Schools and I think
we talked about that last month or at
some point we ran over the charter
school adequacy formula but the charter
school adequacy formula is the left side
of the formula and the additional Grant
and I have notes there on the bottom
about how much the additional Grant is
it's
3552.28 for non-v-lax and then velax
gets 2 300.
so that's a part of the right side of
the formula uh also part of the right
side of the formula is relief Aid which
we just discussed discussed
extraordinary needs part of the right
side of the formula stabilization and
now the governor has a new hold harmless
that he'll be enacting
so
I showed you current law
so if you want to go down to here where
it says Governor proposed 2024 that
shows you what the governor has proposed
and is in hb2
the governor has proposed increasing
base adequacy Aid so you see it was
three eight three thirty eight hundred
under current law the governor is
proposing to bring that up to 4 700. and
so since he's bringing it up on the left
side of the formula it impacts all the
adequacy formulas that are that sync up
with the left side of the formula which
is all of them so it's going to be 4 700
for district adequacy it's going to be 4
700 for Charter adequacy it's going to
be 4 700 for EFA adequacy
the governor is also and all the changes
the governor's proposing are in Gray the
governor is also proposing a change to f
f r
um uh Aid so under current law it's 1900
the governor is proposing to increase it
up to 2500 and so again
it's the left side of the formula so it
applies to District adequacy it applies
to Charter adequacy it applies to EFA
adequacy
the governor is proposing no changes to
the sped rates
um under 20 for fiscal year 24.
um the governor did discuss with the
Full House a full finance committee he
is changing the CPI trigger
um but that deals with fiscal year 24 25
so we'll get to that later just staying
within fiscal year 24 the governor has
no change to spend no change to English
language learner the governor is
removing the third grade reading
component which is about two million
dollars Statewide for district schools
it's a it's one of the smaller portions
of the adequacy left side of the formula
so he is proposing removing that
component
that's in hb2 and so that also again
it's the left side of the formula so
districts Charters efas would lose that
part of the formula but they are gaining
the base adequacy Aid increase in the
fnr increase as well
so moving along uh swept no changes to
swept in Governor's proposed budget
the additional Grant uh no changes to
the additional Grant in the governor's
uh formula the only two things I'll say
is one
um he did add the CPI increase to uh
sorry uh um a two percent
um a two percent adjustment will happen
to the additional Grant every year under
current law it happens every two years
so he'll do a CPI adjustment every two
years he's doing a two percent every
year so that is a change he's proposing
for fiscal year 25 this table is just
representing fiscal year 2024 and and
what I will say take a moment to not go
on a side track but I want to apologize
um I know you have a lot of work to do
and not a lot of time and uh talking
with Hal said
I think they had 96 bills a lot of bills
to go through I think I do still owe you
Mickey's been trying to prioritize
prioritize the bills that need analysis
right away
um so I do owe you a lot of fiscal notes
one of those fiscal fiscal notes is uh
representative Mooney's Bill relative to
Charter Aid
um uh hell said he just came out of the
house floor how sad house floor I think
it's in this committee now um so I'm
going to prioritize getting you the
latest numbers on that so you can make a
decision on that bill with with the best
possible data uh so I apologize for for
those delays back to the formula
um relief Aid the governor is
the governor is proposing uh removing
relief Aid
uh removing relief Aid uh
keeping extraordinary needs Grant
removing stabilization and then building
a new hold harmless Grant and so in the
next tab I'll walk through some of the
math on how that works out on a
Statewide basis and then there's some
also some spreadsheets on how it works
on a Town by Town basis but really I
just wanted you to all remember that the
left side of the formula hits through
just a quick question
in the governor proposed District tag
with adequacy three of the No No and yes
is are underlined any particular meaning
behind that or just uh inconsistency I
don't want to go crazy for a meeting
that was that was that was on purpose so
this what's underlined is because the
governor has changed current law gotcha
under the governor's
um
formula he'd get the charter individual
student would get forty seven hundred
dollars plus whatever of these they'd
get
for Charter yep yep uh base Aid and
differential and
correct and I think didn't we just
um pass a bill that they'd get a
thousand dollars more in-house ad that's
representative Mooney's bill which is in
this committee yes and so that modifies
the additional Grant component um okay
so if you if you choose to uh adopt that
position
um that would add a thousand dollars so
Charters would get a significant
increase they would get a thousand
dollars per people under that bill as
amended by
um I don't know if amended by the house
so I'm going to move on to the next
so there's a lot of numbers on the sheet
there's a lot of details
um so this is kind of something for you
to study maybe we won't go through all
of it but I I just kind of want you run
you through the math if you can look at
The Columns here current current FY 24
so that's current law proposed 24 that's
the governor's proposed 24 adequacy
formula and so here you can kind of see
a head to head
um and see it how it impacts the aid
amounts so when the governor proposes
increasing the raid rate to 4 700 you
can see that base adequacy Aid goes from
a 606 million dollar number to a 737
million dollar number you can see when
he proposes increasing the fnr rate
um it goes from a 73 million dollar to a
94 million dollar number so that's him
increasing Aid on the left side of the
formula and so when we go down to the
bottom and tally that up and then back
out the two million dollars in third
grade reading the grand total there is
150 million dollars an increased Aid on
the left side of the formula so
um but his proposal doesn't cost 150
million over current law some of that is
funded through though decreasing the
right side of the formula so he's
decreased to 17.5 million from the right
side of the formula in the form of
relief Aid he's taken out stabilization
so in grand total that is a decrease of
174 million so we have an increase of
150 million on the left side a decrease
of 174 on the right side of the formula
some communities because they've lost
not really so relief Aid because relief
Aid is pretty much the highest that
Grant could be is 600 per pupil and the
governor's already given over 500 per
people on base f r Aid so really
um
some districts are receiving less Aid
not because of relief Aid being gone but
really because stabilization is gone and
so since stabilization is gone for some
communities if you increase base
adequacy up to 4 700 if you increase fnr
adequacy up to 2500
it does not overcome the the
stabilization grant that they had so
there is a new hold harmless Grant to
hold them harmless in fiscal year 24 and
that one caught that Grant cost 87
million dollars so
um basically funding if you're so
basically the increased Aid on the left
side of the formula is making it less is
making it cheaper than 157 million
dollars it's making it only 87 million
dollars
thank you um
so we know that school district
enrollment room we have gone down
they've been held kind of in this
coveted status for the last three years
are really going to see a decline
in enrollment
overall in their funding because of
their brain reduced lunch numbers are
probably going to go down because their
enrollments have gone down and they're
being held to that not the 2019 numbers
um am I correct so so in 24 25 the hold
harmless and this is we're getting a
little bit into the future here
um I don't know if it's can I put a
pause on that question or okay sorry
okay yeah because it really the answer
is it depends but
but we can we can talk about high level
and how the data might shake out
um
so just just to finish this that is a
good question about how things the
future might look
um we can walk through some examples
the
um so
so there the communities are held
harmless in 24.
um
excess swept uh this is just another
technical aspect of the formula just so
you can see how the math adds up excess
wept under current law is 20 million
dollars so that's the swept above and
beyond the cost of inadequate education
when we tally that up Statewide is 29
million dollars and so when under the
governor's proposed 24 budget
um
say you have a two million dollar swept
this is just getting pretty technical
two million dollar swept one million
dollar cost of an adequate education if
he increases the left side of the
formula formula brings you up to 1.5
million now you only have 500k excess
wept instead of a million excess swept
so the governor's formula and since it's
growing the left side is decreasing
excess swept by about 8 million dollars
so if you do the plus 150 on the left
side increase decrease the one left
right side by 174 add in the hold
harmless then back out the excess swept
you get the change in current law of 54
million dollars so that's just how the
formula sort of balances out
um
I'm going to move on to
the long-term question if there's any
more we have any questions about this
document
so just to since I'm an excess swept
community
it's going to go away
uh no no change no change in excess oh
um so excess swept um
it will go away but it's a measurement
it's just a data point it's not real
dollars so if you're if your community
has a two million dollar swept Grant
your cost of an adequate education is a
million dollars we increase the cost of
an adequate education is 1.5 million
you're so up still 2 million so you
receive your swept no matter what the
governor is proposing no change to swept
it's just the way the funding math works
out from as far as balancing out both
sides the left and right side of the
formula and getting the total to work
out
um there is less excess swept so if
there was yeah but you're not going to
sweep it no no no there's no there's no
change to there's no there's no donor
town There's no you know none of that is
in this bill
just to make sure that I understand this
correctly
if you remain on excess swept the number
of dollars you get does not change it's
just a matter of which pocket you know
stuff comes from if you were a marginal
access swept down now you may actually
get additional dollars because your
adequacy will now exceed what you were
retaining from the swept in the past so
it's a in this it's either a zero loss
or a gain but nobody loses dollars from
that particular side of the formula that
is that's correct okay just making sure
again there are a lot of moving parts
and I want to make sure they fall in the
right place thank you and when you and
when you look at 244 towns you always
see something like that where one town
will go we've never received a check
from the state and then you change the
formula just a little bit or a data
point changes just a little bit and then
they go okay what do I do with this
check I've never received one uh let me
tell book it here
this one the page uh page five
so the governor makes changes to the
formula that go beyond fiscal year 24
25.
uh so 24 25 he's increasing That Base
adequacy uh base adequacy just to start
off 24 is increasing base adequacy Aid
uh he's also increasing f r Aid he's
also making that two percent adjustment
each year so in your current law there's
a CPR adjustment every two years he's
making a two percent adjustment each
year
um so he isn't that's gonna have
long-term effects um when you increase
two percent each year each year each
year each year it's going to increase
the eight amount at a faster clip
especially faster than every other year
um
he also is going to phase out that hold
harmless Grant starting in fiscal year
26. so starting in fiscal year 26 over a
10-year period he is going to uh every
two years going to reduce the hold
harmless Grant by 20 percent
as he's reducing the hold harmless Grant
by 20 percent uh the proposed budget is
also
uh increasing the extraordinary needs
Grant by 50 in the aid amount so I
should have done the math I should have
written out the math before
um but if you do 650 times 50 percent
it's like 900 something dollars
um then you do 50 times that it's like
twelve hundred dollars per F in our
student and then 50 times that and so he
does that through five iterations so the
it's really difficult
to predict the future
um really difficult to to to to to know
what what's gonna happen when student
enrollment so just assuming
a one percent enrollment decline which
is actually pretty normal
um covid we had a four percent
enrollment decline
um which was abnormal but normally we
have a one percent enrollment decline
um likely just based on demographic
information
if you if you assume a one percent
enrollment decline
and you assume that Medicaid direct cert
I believe that bill is in this committee
uh Medicaid direct cert which uh will
not be enacted it's not in hb2 and it
will not be enacted unless the
legislature enacts it um the department
will not move forward with Medicaid
direct cert but if we assume Medicaid
direct assert is passed by the
legislature and signed by the governor
and is implemented in fiscal year 26
which is when we hypothetically think we
it would be implemented
um if you make those assumptions and try
to model out to the next 10 years
basically what will happen is that hold
harmless Grant and then we include the
hold harmless Grant decreasing by 20
each year and we include the
extraordinary needs Grant increasing by
50 parade Aid amount
um over a 10-year period you'll kind of
see what happens in the blue is base Aid
going up it's going up by two percent
each year as the enrollment declines uh
um it is still gonna
if we assume a one percent enrollment
decline that one percent two percent
increase in base Aid is going to Eclipse
that so just to go back to
representative Heath's question
when we look at
the past with adequacy we we have our
CPI adjustment every two years it's
typically two percent we have in a one
percent enrollment decline that really
kind of holds districts flat and
actually kind of has them lose money
kind of in the long run especially
during covet there was that 90 million
dollar well it was based on one time
made but there was a large shortfall
when when the covert um when the coveted
started impacting the adequacy formula
um
so kind of just saying assuming one
percent enrollment decline which is the
Statewide average which will be
different for each Community some
communities have three percent some
computers will increase students
um
it looks like the aid amount will
increase overall
um so this is just a Statewide average
of what it will look like it will look
like the increase in base adequacy Aid
and the increase in extraordinary needs
will kind of
wash out the loss in the hold harmless
Grant that's at a Statewide basis how it
would shake out for each individual Town
um depends but looking at the larger
Statewide roll-up uh that's how it would
shake out
so that's that's what again based on all
these assumptions based on Medicaid
director being enacted based on a one
percent enrollment decline
um based on what we think the data might
look like in the future
kind of going to wash out there and what
this also doesn't include is this
doesn't also include the
sped rate getting the two percent
increase the ell rate getting the two
percent increase
um so that's going to give a little
extra boost in this number in the long
term
so that's
kind of the the 10-year Outlook but when
you have hb2 in front of you you will
see that there is a hold harmless Grant
hold harmless grant that phases out over
10 years an extraordinary needs grant
that increases for over a 10-year period
every two years uh that's the changes in
the formula that the governor has for 26
so the next page is whatever everyone
wants to see the town by town
so page six oh sorry
just really quickly uh you don't need to
go back to page five but just
I appreciate that you know you guys had
to um
just show the top of the graph because I
don't think they make paper that's quite
big enough for us to see that detail if
you printed the whole thing but you know
just wanted to note for the record that
that's just the top of the graph so the
changes are you know
the exaggerated versus the total number
yes so it's otherwise we wouldn't have
seen anything meaningful so I know why
you did it
I just want to say that I've seen this
hole will reduce the stabilization Grant
in the past and you acknowledge that I'm
kind of worry of 10 year plans
because
um you know born and raised in a
communist country with our five-year
plans they didn't really work that great
for us so uh for now I'm just gonna look
at it as what we are planning to do this
biennium and not really spend a lot of
time on the forecast because the
forecast depends on future legislatures
and you know whatever happens there so
that yeah uh we we routinely do
estimates for 10-year adequacy
um and we say the uh the estimates are
fine as long as no one looks at it in
the in the future
but yeah it's very difficult to um uh
very difficult to estimate adequacy in
so the town by town
so page six you'll see the state totals
at the top
so under current law uh fiscal year 24
so if if
if
the legislature did nothing fiscal year
24 would be current law which we
estimate to be 962 million dollars and
this is the town by town to how we got
to that number
uh fiscal year 24 Governors proposed the
governor is is looking to increase
adequacy Aid at a Statewide basis by 54
million dollars up to a billion 17
million
um
and so you can see some towns
um you can see a lot of hash marks uh
dashes that's zero change they're
getting the same amount they would under
current law under the governor's
proposed and so there's there's kind of
two reasons for that really
um you're either a whole harmless town
so you're receiving a hold harmless
Grant to hold harmless Grant holds you
to what the current law estimate is so
it would exactly fall on the Zero
um exactly be zero change
if you are a community that
is receiving additional funding it's
because those changes in base adequacy
Aid the change to up to 4 700 or the
change up to 2500 in fnr in the rates
has worked out in a way that that either
one eclipses whatever your stabilization
was so it eclipses whatever moved away
from the formula or you might not have
been a stabilization town and it's just
every dollar increases your adequacy Aid
amount I mean you didn't have any loss
on the right side of the formula you
only had growth in the left side of the
formula
um so this is the the town by Town
um
I think
I'm just going to go through this
document I don't if we have any
when you say stabilization we are
talking about the governor's new
proposed stabilization formula in in the
context of the statement you just made
oh that's no actually that's a good
question so
um stabilization sometimes sometimes
it's called the whole harmless Grant
when we say stable it just to get our
jargon on the on the right terms here
when we're talking about stabilization
we are talking about the 2012 Grant the
grant that's going away
when we're talking about the governor's
new hold harmless which is a a similar
it's similar mechanically to
stabilization it's different
um we call it hold harmless so that's
going to be just so we're on the same
terms so every town with a zero with a
no net change was in the old
stabilization uh or some of them are
excess swept so I was going to run
through an example like Alton Alton is
an excess I'm not going to jump ahead
up up on the town by town on page six
I'll point you out uh to one scenario if
you look at Bradford
so it's location code
let's see where it is location code 59
it's in the middle of the sheep Bradford
um their current law is 1.2 million
in fiscal year 24. the governor proposed
is 1.2 million in fiscal year 24. and so
they are
um being they are stay or stabilization
town uh even though the aid Ace uh base
Aid has been increased even though fnr8
has been increased it did not Eclipse
whatever their stabilization they lost
was so they are being Net Zero
ah
where some communities like Bradford
will start off as a whole harmless town
will turn into not a whole harmless town
in fiscal year 24 so they were barely a
whole harmless town and fiscal year 24
but you had that two percent increase
um
uh to base Aid so it's going to go from
4 700 to
4794 dollars
um that little bump made them not a
whole harmless town so some communities
over time
um this assumes flat enrollment
um will will Eclipse their hold harmless
um so Bradford is just one example if we
assume flat enrollment
um if Bradford had declining enrollment
they might not if they have declining
enrollment next year they might not
Eclipse their hold harmless Grant
um so just so you know that predicting
the future how the variables will play
out in the future really depend on a lot
of variables really what was your what's
the size of your whole harmless Grant
what's the size of what's your
enrollment situation so declining
enrollment
um uh the two percent bump it is going
to help you out but if you have
significant declining enrollment it's
probably not going to help you Eclipse
whatever your stabilization was and
we'll run through some scenarios but
some some communities uh have a really
high hold harmless that if you kind of
look at the math and you kind of look
forward they're probably it's very
unlikely they're going to Eclipse their
hold harmless
um but certain communities they might
seem like a whole harmless town now but
in the future depending on how their
enrollment is if they're enrollment's
stable and they're just getting a two
percent bump in their base rate they're
likely going to you know maybe Eclipse
their hold harmless
um also if they're an extraordinary
needs Grand town so in the future I know
we're not we're talking about staying to
the 24 25 budget but just to talk about
the long-term trends of what is in hb2
um those were the factors that would
yeah thank you Mr just again trying to
translate this into English so I can
make sure I really understood it
correctly the governors proposed
approached over the long term to uh you
know cleaning up the formal
stabilization you know distortions if
is to essentially you know create their
hold harmless which make sure nobody
loses a dollar and over time kind of
hold the towns that used to be in
stabilization flat while everybody else
is catching up so that nobody has to
have funds taken away from them but the
towns that we're getting what one could
characterize as excess funds because of
the old stabilization would just grow a
bit slower until everybody caught up I'm
just trying to again wrap my head around
it and make sure I understand the
internet I guess another way of asking
this would be through the whole plan
forecast of the governor will a town
that's currently in stabilization will
is it ever a scenario where they could
lose dollars yes okay so the hold
harmless so they're held harmless in
24-25 so there's no situation that they
could lose money in 24.25 because
they're held harmless but 26 and Beyond
uh there is a phase out of the hold
harmless so
if you decrease your hold harmless Grant
by 20 percent
um you in in whatever you're seeing in
that CPI increase that two percent
increase the extraordinary needs it may
or may not eclipse the loss you're
experiencing I appreciate your
clarification as you said there are a
lot of moving Parts 26 and Beyond so so
some communities are going to be able to
Eclipse it some communities uh based on
the math very likely will not Eclipse it
much appreciated I think if you look at
your chart on page five it's fairly
obvious that the 20 uh FY 26 bar in
total is shorter yes
so that's
um yeah sorry you don't have hb2 in
front of you but um starting in 26 you
see that 20 decline in the hold harmless
Grant
um and so 26 20 decline in the hold
harmless Grant
um uh and then no change basically you
hold that basically you hold 80 of your
hold armless grant for
um fiscal year 27.
um in fiscal year 26 also you see the
the Boost to extraordinary needs Grant
so the a per pupil and that one is 900
900 something dollars
um per fnr pupil
um
so yeah when you look at 26 you'll see
the first reduction on page five when
you look at 26 you see the first
reduction in the brown bar which is hold
harmless
some of that is also um uh
a boost to it's also when we assume
that's when we start that's without a
plugged in Medicaid direct cert numbers
Medicaid directs certain numbers which
uh the estimate could be anywhere to 9
000 additional uh f r students to 18 000
it's that's another
very hard variable to predict
um uh it could add 22 million to 42
million under current law to the
adequacy formula
um I think it's probably closer to the
22 million side but that's another
another thing in the future that's going
to be hard to predict
thank you can we put Medicaid direct
yes you can so
House Bill six ten 601 oh 601 right yeah
so that that we have a work session
scheduled for Tuesday
uh to discuss that and similar to the
other bills we've retained that could be
something since it directly impacts the
uh calculation of adequacy I would
recommend that be part of Hospital too
thank you
um
didn't did we get 529 yet or
it's individual
it's our it's came to us from the floor
so that's another funding bill
do you have we run the numbers on that
one
95 million dollars
95. representative fellows around the
numbers I double checked them because
I'm in a whole job
she sent me her numbers did I send them
to you Mickey
yes we
[Music]
okay thank you could we get a print out
of those then at some point
no
what
was that uh Representatives fellows ran
uh
data sheet on um House Bill 529
that some of us have
seen but not all of us so I think Mickey
has a copy of it
we do so we have the work session
scheduled for that as well on Tuesday
perfect so we can bring that print out
if you want we don't have a fiscal note
on that bill yet you said 529. so we
don't have anything official from the
Department I think Mark said he had
double check that word so we have lots
of options what's your relation to
Logistics additional eight grants for
school based on free and reduced price
meals and fiscal capacity disparity
so if if I was just going to go through
this document really hard unless anyone
I kind of interrupted you when you were
going through the original you know
example were there other examples you
were going to go through or did the
discussion after replace the need for
the other towns you were I was going to
try to do it through this document it's
very hard to read I apologize my uh so
one of the tricks here when you're
looking at adequacy spreadsheet is if
you pulled up the bottom you can usually
line it up with uh line it up with a
town
um so we'll start with Acworth Acworth
is the top town here so this is just the
governor's formula in the the
spreadsheet format the format that um
that uh the saus would receive this as
if this became law
um so Acworth has 87 students 87 times
the 47 uh four thousand seven hundred
dollars gets you 408 000 F and R we're
estimating them to have 28 f r students
times the 2500
that gets a seventy thousand dollars
sped no changes there 19 students times
2079 we get the 39 000 amount they do
not have any English language Learners
in Acworth so no age no Aid there the
governor now has taken out the third
grade component the third grade
component is usually in the adequacy
spreadsheet we get the total cost of an
adequate education it's 518 000 under
the governor's formula we subtract swept
so it looks like we need around three
hundred thousand dollars at a minimum in
a check cut from the state to make sure
the three hundred thousand dollars plus
the swept of 221 000 would get them
approximately that five hundred and
eighteen thousand dollars they need to
fund their schools uh to provide the
opportunity for an adequate education
so for Acworth um we do 518k minus 221 k
then we add their extraordinary needs
Grant they have a very small
extraordinary needs Grant fourteen
hundred dollars
um
uh by the way also in hb2 uh you'll see
this when you get hp2 uh
any Community that's receiving less than
fifty thousand dollars in extraordinary
needs Grant doesn't need to do an
accountability plan so that was
something so it just exempts any small
any grant that any small grants are
exempt from doing an accountability plan
so Acworth doesn't have to do an
accountability plan on a fourteen
hundred dollar Grant
um
uh we tally that up um it actually
wasn't 300K it was 298k 200 2 000 uh 298
584 that's their preliminary Grant
that's the cost of an adequate education
minus swept plus the extraordinary needs
Grant
um but then here fiscal year 24 the
brown column
that is the hold harmless we're holding
them to we're holding them to what does
24 current law say and so it says 469
000.
so uh they are going to be held harmless
to that uh the uh so if you have 298 000
you plus a hundred and seventy thousand
you get them back up to that 469 000. so
this is just one Community where the
whole harmless Grant is pretty
substantial
um if Acworth were to grow their
population
um
they might be held harmless in the
future meaning they might have enough
Aid in the future to Eclipse their their
current uh hold homeless Grant
um that's again talking about 26 and
Beyond but for fiscal year 24 and 25
they are going to receive 469 000
inadequacy Grant no matter what
um no matter how at a minimum sorry not
no matter what at a minimum so we have
the hundred and seventy thousand
plus the 298 000 and the preliminary
Grant and we get a number of uh 469 000.
so that is how a hold harmless Grant
Works flows through the spreadsheet
now going further I'm going to pick on
Amherst because Amherst was I think the
first community that received additional
Aid
let's see Amherst yep it's location code
so Amherst has
1795 students
times that by the base adequacy eight
amount we get 8.4 million
they have 106 f r students times that by
the twenty five hundred dollars we get
263k
sped 290 times the 2079 603
English language Learners 13 times 756
we get the 9787.
now we got the total cost of inadequate
education for them is 9.3 million
uh minus the swept so that will come
into play and minus the swept ends up
being 5.7 million
um so the cost of an adequate education
is 9.3 million swept is 3.5 million so
they're not an access web Community they
are not an extraordinary needs Grant
Community
their Grant at a minimum is looking to
be at least 5.7 million we look at what
they were good under current law it's
4.2 million so they don't need to hold
harmless Grant because what they're
receiving under the governor's formula
is greater than what they would receive
under current law so no hold harmless
Grant is needed so they receive a uh
adequacy Grant of 5.7 million when you
add in the stabilization swept Grant
uh start not added stabilization I'm
sorry add in the Swift Grant plus the
adequacy grant we get 9.3 million so
that's an that's how a non-hold harmless
would would work out and why is Amherst
a non-hold harmless well it could be a
lot of reasons the likely reason is they
were not a stabilization town or if they
are a stabilization town the increase in
base adequacy and f r adequacy eclipses
whatever the stabilization was so that
is how the formula works for
um around around half of the communities
are like Amherst where they're receiving
around 100 communities so a little less
than half are around the are similar to
Amherst where they're receiving
additional Aid through the formula
and then I Alton is I'll go up to Alton
and this is the other scenario
Alton it's a location code 15.
uh six one from the top
so Alton has 576 kids and I'll go
through this a little bit quicker here
but if we scroll over to their cost of
inadequate education Alton's cost of an
adequate education is 3.2 million their
swept is 3.7 million so they don't need
additional funding because they have
enough money through their swept to
cover the cost of an adequate education
so their cost of an adequate education
previously was something less than 3.2
million
um
um but whatever increases they've got on
base rate and fnr did not make them
greater than swept so they they did not
become a an adequacy Town they're still
just an excess webtown so no changes in
their funding formula so they're held
they're held neutral but not held
harmless there's all there's towns
getting additional Aid Town's getting uh
held harmless and towns just sort of
being held neutral
oh
I think it's a lot to digest all the the
numbers and the three different kinds of
categories of how this could affect your
town you know whether or not you're
neutral whether or not you're better off
and whether or not you're taking
advantage of this hold harmless period
of time I think um it'll be interesting
to to see the Shakedown of how this
affects people across the state and you
know how they might feel about that so
well one thing's for sure you'll hear
other question mark I just want to say
thank you this is a an amazing amazing
amazing amount of work and I I bet you
were up late a lot of nights and all the
people from the Department I want to
thank you all because they're just
amazing all the work that you do thank
you
and just a very quick thought for
everybody involved
everybody's going to be happy this
biennium right it's a uh no no loss or
get extra funding the reason why I was
asking about when does the pain start is
that I would rather make sure as much as
possible that the people who may see
their funding drop talk about this now
rather than wait for two years until
their funding starts dropping and then
complain at the last moment so
whatever we can do you know at every
level to inform the school districts of
you know what is going on so we can get
feedback now it would be valued rather
than uh you know having a surprise quote
unquote and then a knee-jerk reaction in
two years so
joke
yeah thank you yeah I think this is the
best job I've seen yet so thank you
uh
I was looking at Farmington and uh it
kind of it's kind of flat
but stable the stabilization's been
tried before to get rid of it and uh it
worked for what couple
I think 2017 2018 2019 yeah so three
years so farmington's stabilization
right large stabilization and it doesn't
make any I mean I shouldn't be saying
this but it doesn't make any sense
keep getting it thank you Mr chairman
so we keep putting free and reduced in
the same category what's the difference
in incomes whether you get free meal or
I don't I don't know if someone has the
um actual income amounts but it's a
hundred and thirty five percent for free
in 185 percent of the federal poverty
guideline for reduced
so adequacy only cares about um if
you're 185 or under
um 185 or under under the uh reduce 130.
130 is free
um 130 is free but for the purpose of
adequacy only the only number that
matters is under 185 percent
no other questions thank you very much
oh yeah
sure
that's good you've got to come up to the
mic
thank you very much Mr chair Dave luno
from education I was just wondering if
if Mark could talk a little bit about
the um the the the the second most um
column to the um to the right
so that's this is actually the column
that the that the proposed formula would
would calculate correct is that right
and then how that might change over
over time whether that's through CPI
because that will reflect
that's the reflection of the formula
correct so going back to kind of the
what we've sort of seen historically
um it's been a really hard time looking
at data during covet covid really messed
up a lot of data sets for us but
generally the data has been pretty
stable for schools and you kind of sort
of saw it just sort of the the one
percent enrollment Decline and then the
two-year change in the CPI it's sort of
just kind of just flat is that your
experience when you look at the
historical data yeah sort of just flat
maybe a little bit down
um
and so
I think if you assume a one percent
if so if we've historically done a two
percent CPI every two years and so if we
assume if now for doing that every year
and we assume a one percent enrollment
decline it's not going to be flat it's
going to increase
um
um so it's a good increase in the future
the formula is now
going to increase more in the future if
we can keep on holding that two percent
um over what it's done historically
which is the CPI every two years
so that's is that was that your question
yeah that's that's sort of it and I
guess just from a from an observation
standpoint with all that said so that
that number would increase just ever so
slightly
um every year but another way to look at
this is that in the first If This Were
to become law in the in the first um two
first biennium you'd have the final the
column on the right would be the Grant
and then over a 10-year period it would
move towards that column just to the
left of that
oh so you're talking about decreasing
excess web
no no no I'm talking about the
decreasing the hold harmless that
um so Statewide on a Statewide basis
um
um and this is what this this table
um so again holding a lot of assumptions
into the future this table attempts this
this page page five attempts to kind of
uh think about 10 years into the future
it makes assumptions assumptions like
Medicaid direct cert is enacted uh makes
assumptions about enrollment decline
um it triggers the 20 reduction and hold
harmless it triggers the 50 increase in
the extraordinary needs Grant and at a
Statewide lab basis it's going to show
increased Aid amount so it's going to
show it increasing over time
but how it impacts each individual
Community depends on multiple variables
thank you Mr chair
um while you're on page five
if you look at the numbers on the bottom
what originally tripped me and the
reason why I originally missed the drop
in 2026 was I kind of read the bottom
number and I assumed that was the total
it's not it's three numbers that you've
got to add up if you want to maybe edit
that chart and throw a total at the
bottom oh it would it would be much
easier for a number driven person rather
than a graphics driven person to notice
the drop you know that's just me because
I read numbers and the real question
that I wanted to ask was obviously we
have a bill coming up which has to do
with direct enrollment in Medicaid
um as far as the Educational Funding is
concerned there have been concerns
brought up earlier in our previous meet
you know hearings and work sessions that
because of the drop in the number of
people filing the fnr paperwork because
they don't have to because they get the
meals for free because of the you know
covid related measures it may be good
policy to just stop using the fnr and
shift towards using you know the number
of Medicaid eligible kids whether they
are enrolled or not could you comment a
little bit in terms of what are those
income guidelines and would those
measures be equivalent would they be
acceptable to substitute one for another
or how would we handle the potential
transition you know like that because we
are all aware I think that right now the
fnr part is Under reporting the students
so we are not funding the districts
accurately
and you know whether that legislation
passes or not we may want to just adjust
the formula nonetheless to get the more
accurate representation of the you know
percentage of kids in poverty if you
want
this discussion came out with house uh
and how sad uh over house house bill 601
there are some states that do not they
say no applications they they drop the
applications uh House Ed can speak about
the house position but the house
the house as they pass that bill and put
into this committee they were aware that
they could make it State policy that no
more applications they did not put that
into the law so the house position
currently has a past the house floor is
that you will have the option to direct
certify you also have the option to
complete the application but there are
some communities that are just
Massachusetts I believe
um it might just be the Boston School
District it might be all of
Massachusetts but they don't I think
they've foregone even using fnr
applications and just focus really on
their direct cert numbers to get their
Federal money
um
yeah so some some states do it
um the house education was discussing
that that same exact policy question
my question was a bit slightly different
even though the measure positive house
you know that is a long way until that
measure may become law and I don't want
to assume that it's going to become law
and I want to make sure I understand how
could we
adjust our formulas to prepare for
either a scenario whether this goes
through all the way and gets a signature
or it doesn't in terms of fixing that
fnr formula issue
so uh
in in
that you bring up a good question trying
to there's a lot of uncertainty uh
there's some uncertainty in the in the
adequacy calculation we have for 24.25
there's always uncertainty usually we're
off by millions of dollars it's a
billion dollar calculation so my oh I
always recommend you do not spend every
last dollar the education trust fund
um Because unless you really really are
confident in those adequacy estimates
um leave a little bit money in there
because we will likely have a uh like
this past year uh Mickey and I worked on
the numbers Mickey relies on the
Department's Department to provide him
data and we work with the LBA to do a
budget estimate we
under budgeted by three million dollars
for 22 we essentially over budgeted by
nine million dollars so you can it's
very easy to make a single million
dollar digit swing
um in an adequacy estimate so so that's
usually the margin of error that three
million dollars uh three to ten million
dollars can can be kind of the margin of
error with adequacy it's very easy to
have those swings
um so the only recommendation is I keep
us keep some money in the education
trust fund to deal with that or keep or
in the general fund however you want to
deal with it
um but then also yeah uh Medicaid
director would not impact the adequacy
formula in 26 so it's not really a 24 25
budgeting concern it is a structural
concern in a sense that it will create
future legislatures we'll have to deal
with it from a budgeting perspective so
however you want to manage that
potential liability in the future is is
definitely something strategically you
can think about
um but Medicaid director has a yeah a a
26 26 and Beyond impact if that were to
enacted and if we were to enter the
pilot program and the USDA would approve
us all those all those factors would be
contingent upon all those factors
I appreciate it and one last follow-up
I obviously agree with what you said but
we have a structural issue right now
right with the fnr being unreported by a
lot of districts which you know I don't
know how much we want to wait or not and
I was just wondering if we have data on
what would uh you know happen if we uh
tweaked the formula right now to rely on
you know Medicaid daily eligibility
numbers not necessarily on enrollments
to substitute for the fnr and that would
obviously require changes to the formula
um so there's two ways to do it to do it
the way uh and this came up in in
previous legislature uh previous work
sessions with house ad and and house
findings have dealt with this particular
issue the challenge with using we can't
Department of Education can't touch
Medicaid data right now because we need
authorization from the center of
Medicaid services and we don't get that
Medicaid services until we enter that
pilot so our the Department of Education
is completely blind to which students
are on Medicaid because we don't have
access to that data because it's it's
highly private and regulated we need
authorization from the federal
government to access that um DHS will
not uh let us access that data so we
can't match it to the student to help
inflate the F uh not inflate but throw
the fnr numbers or um until that happens
um the alternative option which um would
be to just take the Medicaid number and
use it and build a design a new formula
via the grant take the Medicaid numbers
and just build say the Medicaid numbers
exist we have the data let's build a new
Grant it's not going to link to a
particular student but that that would
be the only way we could do a now
um
um not using Medicare director thank you
because all you're really doing is
looking to put a number in that box how
you get the number is the question
correct it would just be a new if if you
went that route it would just be a new
part of the formula and it would be a
new data set
um a new data set that represents
poverty different than the data set
we're currently using which is fnr
right uh thank you Mr chairman
um
being reduced have you seen any uh you
mentioned Boston as a the way they well
they don't collect the data anymore how
much does it cost to collect this data
because I know in my district it's like
a hot potato you know you take it no you
take it and it you know and it does cost
I mean somebody's this to spends you
probably don't realize how much time it
takes to you know collect all this data
because you got to send the forms out
you're hoping get them back you keep
pinging on you know the you know the
parents to to bring them in which on my
district is I mean it's terrible it's
144 less uh you know students on free
and reducing there was last last uh last
time we checked I mean that's that
that's something to think about we don't
have any any data to report on the like
numerical data report on the
administrative costs but we see we
always talk to the seus we tell them
it's important to get that F in our
application they say we're trying our
best it's really challenging and it's an
ongoing conversation we have with them
we're like we you know we know it's hard
you have to keep trying and uh but yeah
a lot of it's a challenge right and a
follow-up to that to the Medicaid
you you have access to the numbers right
per Town per Town yeah so so I mean that
would that would fit in the formula to
fit that could be fit it is it is the
data is granular enough that it is
captured at the municipal level that it
could be rolled into adequacy
um but it could not be rolled into the
student level data
um it just the sum totals we do have
that data probably level of that town
the only thing we don't have is when
DHHS gave us the data they don't have
DHHS doesn't collect data on Pinnacle
but Penacook is a municipal so there
would be some adjustments and tweaks
with some of the communities
um just mainly just kind of cook I think
but we have assuming the DHT data DHS
gave us is good we have that data thank
you
nope
this data doesn't seem to reflect 100
million we took out of swept but 2023.
ah yeah that was just fiscal year 23
one-time swept reduction
doesn't apply in this does not apply in
fiscal year 24.
we showed 2023 in here
oh that's 2024. did I say 2023
oh school year 2023. so it's the adm's
adequacy the student data is one year
behind so we're going to use the school
year data from 2223 those student counts
are going to fund fiscal year 24. so
it's the fiscal year 24 formula which is
based on student data from the year
behind
and I I don't think any of us have yet
seen the reduction
in that 100 million so uh tax bills tax
rates were set this past fall
and it should have included
the sweat reduction
about 50 cents on attack but 50 cents
didn't reduce didn't seem to reduce the
taxes so yeah there's the it's it
there's the uh there's four taxes as you
know four taxes you pay uh typical
taxpayer residential uh sorry um typical
residential commercial taxpayer pays
Muni uh County local school state Ed and
so the total racks tax rate might be
going up in your community but the sweat
might have decreased a little bit uh but
you guys bring that up to your school
board municipal government and your
County uh to find out what happened
that was set right at the uh when they
set the tax rate because that didn't get
to the school district
per se I mean you know the overall rate
is you know they in other words it
didn't go to the schools it went to the
tax rate
uh yeah I reduced the tax rate which
will decrease the swept funding the
school receive but it's happening yeah
there's a there's a tax year and a
school year and a fiscal year and they
all kind of it all gets worked out by
dra I can't really speak to all the
different scheduling that happens there
situation
another thing that Mickey and I have
been talking a little bit about this and
uh uh chairwoman uh representative
umberger also uh discussed it as well
um the other day
the fiscal committee back in I think
December
changed the snap eligibility from 185 to
200.
they did that I think in December and so
if you increase the snap eligibility
more students are going to be now
eligible for fnr the numbers I have
produced
the number of frr students I'm carrying
for fiscal year 24 25 on these
spreadsheets in the governor's budget
does not in does not include any
increase for how many students might be
added to uh
um
might be added to the fnr numbers
because they're 185 percent to 200
percent that program has been in
operation since January so I I just
actually
um just emailed director Herbert to say
hey do you have any data on how many
kids are how many kids are showing up
for the 185 200 range
um DHHS made an original estimate they
think there's six thousand around six
thousand six to sixty five hundred
students potentially out there
um if you take 6 500 we don't know where
those students live but they estimate
that there potentially could be 6 500
students out there
if you take 6 500 students and just
assume they live exactly where all the f
r students live and run it through the
formula it has an annualized cost of 20
I'm not carrying it on here it's not
carried on here because I don't have
that data and I don't know if DHS has
data DHS did an estimate so I'm gonna
hopefully get information from DHHS
about how successful that program is it
may be successful it may not be
successful I don't know it may be six
thousand kids it may be less
um so it's another uncertainty in your
budget and so
um what what Mickey thought about and I
thought maybe when Mickey said that
might be an option that you might have
to deal with this from a budgeting
perspective is there's uncertainty there
it could be a 20 million dollar cost
it just might be something you want to
carry on your Surplus statement
um so I'm sorry to make the bad news
that you have 20 million dollars in cost
what's actually really unknown we don't
know we we think it will cost 20 million
dollars but another another potential
uh Financial liability that might be out
there that was fiscal committee made
that decision that program started
getting enacted in January so we're
gonna have a half year of that program
running for this fiscal year which will
impact 24. so if we say a half year of
20 million dollars let's say 10 million
dollars in
um
uh uh 10 million dollars and 24 maybe 25
20 million dollars in in 25
I really don't know
um just based on DHS data that's the
I think it's providing more benefits
because it's expanding the eligibility
cool
um and it's Federal money from a dhhss
perspective where the state's cost is
we'll see it in our eoi we'll see it in
our eoi when we finish the school year
and try to tally up all the students
that were educated in 2223 we'll also
get the latest direct search data and so
we'll see it this summer we'll know well
it's a summer we'll know what what does
that program look like in half a year of
operation
um we'll have well a final number for
24. so we might see a 10 million dollar
boost
so yeah so so is that snap TANF is that
direct cert now
correct okay so and that's been in in
enforced for a long time snap TANF has
been operating for
um a long time I don't know how long
right right because I I've seen it
before 2000 and
2006. okay the change to 185 to 200
eligibility is effective January one
very good thank you I just wanted to
take a moment to thank you for bringing
that potential feature uh issue up
because 20 million or 30 million is not
exactly a rounding error or any budget
and I think it behooves us to budget for
the worst case scenario here because the
one thing we cannot afford to do is run
out of uh you know funds so while it is
possible that some of those people are
in districts where they would fall under
the 12 percent and maybe they will not
affect the final formula it would be
imprudent of us to be optimistic about
it and I would rather have
you know a bit too much money left in
the fund at the end but be sure that we
can pay our obligations than the other
way around so seriously that's honestly
the kind of information that I would
have never you know gotten if I just
read about it so I really appreciate the
Insight thank you after I have to say it
was Mickey who said Mark we got it we
gotta talk about this and Mickey's gonna
Mickey's gonna hold he's gonna build
your Surplus statement with you and he's
gonna make sure you you balance thing
out and you have all the all as the
commissioner said all the debits and
credits in front of you so
um you're in good hands
I I will give credit to the former chair
who reminded me to remind you today so
uh so yes to clarify what Mark's
referring to with the Surplus statement
whatever you decide to do this
committee's recommendation for Education
funding will will calculate it to the
best that we can based on the data that
we have that data we just don't have on
a Town by Town basis so depending on the
policy that you approve we can come up
with an estimate that you could have on
the Surplus statement to reflect this
additional cost that will be in the end
of year counts that we just don't know
we won't know for your timeline to do a
house budget so if I read this properly
then and using the governor's numbers
148 million dollars so yes looking at
this uh snapshot this education trust
fund snapshot So based on the governor's
recommended budget with the governor's
Revenue estimates in there for now your
starting point before Ways and Means
does the revenue adjustments and before
you touch House Bill wanted the house
bill 2 the education trust fund has 148
million dollar Surplus even after all
the uh proposals and everything you've
I think we've gone through quite a bit
of information today oh
foreign
okay and I will remind sorry if I can
representative you might be getting this
we do have a work session on uh Tuesday
we have 10 education related bills so
you you may see some of these folks back
again uh four of which you know we kind
of discussed just this afternoon with
Mark plus we've got others uh throughout
the Department of Education uh the other
six bills so and we're back tomorrow at
10. back tomorrow at 10.
okay
we'll close this work session we'll see
foreign